[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we are yeah i said when i
first came on i was like well i don't
want the glasses on because that kind of
like ruins everything
but i can't see it yeah you know who
this is
oh you found one
i was telling you earlier i'm like you
gotta find a light bulb
and he's like i can't find one because
all we have is like those curly led ones
i was like we gotta have an old one
around here somewhere
who knows where that light bulb has been
oh that's that's one of those that's not
what that's not like one of the old ones
because i said hey i've got an old one
like up in the ceiling fan there but who
knows where the [ __ ] how long that's
been in there it's probably let's see
what everybody's doing i just came in i
was feeding the trick or treaters and if
they if they rig i gotta run down there
and go get them yeah
yeah we had actually like uh quite we
had more than i thought we would yeah
they do they do it differently in this
neighborhood
well they were showing up in damn
electric golf carts pulling trailers of
kids
had three electric golf carts each one
of them with a trailer like something
you carry lawn mowers on and they were
in the back
so i got swarmed there that last that
last raid they're hitting this hole
because the distance between the house
is big yeah so they're running through
here like in a [ __ ] posse
i get it that's actually a really good
idea yeah you know what i mean yeah uh
you know cause like i said we're kind of
in a slightly rural area and like you
said the houses are a lot farther apart
so it's probably better to have i saw i
didn't see a golf cart but i saw like a
pickup truck
with uh with a thing on the back that
had a bunch of kids in it what are the
costumes i didn't see them oh just all
kinds of [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] that's
that's helpful
i think we got a super oh thank you no
need for me too thank you nice costume
happy all hallows eve chilling in my
dad's garage for the last time
what kind of candy did you get says
karen rob we got
um
mini snickers like the little snickers
and we got kit kats and reese's peanut
butter cups cause that's really the only
good halloween candy
i'm not one of those people it's gonna
give out that cheap ass like [ __ ] hey
here's some dum-dums and tootsie rolls
cause [ __ ] that noise nobody likes those
[Laughter]
okay just catching up with stuff
i was just watching i was uh reading a
thing earlier
where
they had done like i guess there's like
a ranking of
well it's purportedly
the favorite halloween candy in every
state in the u.s
but the way they do it the way they
compile it is from google searches not
from sales i'm like but yeah that's not
i mean just because somebody's searching
for something that doesn't mean they
necessarily like it and it's like
because some states like the number one
search thing was like circus peanuts and
i'm like nobody
likes circus penis yeah okay so it's
like i'm sure that google search was
probably what the [ __ ] are circus
peanuts or why the [ __ ] do circus
peanuts even exist
and then that counted as like a win i
don't i don't see that that's just
that's that's some [ __ ] right there
i don't know i
i i kind of feel like um i think some
states like number ones were like nerds
or airheads or something like that which
are kind of like which fine but
i don't know like i said i've always
been like more of a chocolate
candy person especially for halloween no
need for me too sent a 10 super chat
thank you very much what do you say
there yeah i saw that nice costume happy
all hallows eve chilling in my dad's
garage for the last time
i don't know why he's chilling in his
dad's garage for last time i don't know
it's a dad pass or something i don't
know what it was i don't know the story
behind that
i was thinking too that um apparently i
don't know i don't see anybody around
here doing it but i've heard that
a trend for halloween the last few years
is not only to like give out candy to
like all the kids and stuff that are
going by but some uh some enterprising
families will also have stuff for the
parents
like booze
like they'll have like tables out front
and they'll have like jello shots for
the grown-ups and candy for the kids and
i'm like i heartily endorse that oscar
perez asks if you have if we have uh
cash app jenny has cash out i do yeah
yes yeah
and it's just under jenny ashford i
think
i don't use it all that often yeah i
just have like one i have one client
that uses that everybody else well
probably is a picture of you though huh
does it
i don't know
it probably doesn't because i don't
think i ever like got that [ __ ]
ready you know what i mean right because
it's kind of like i only just got it
because one person was like i don't have
paypal or i don't use paypal or whatever
and i had to do cash app so i have it on
my phone but i don't remember if it's
all set up or anything yet
all right i hate to say it but i have to
put my glasses on so i can read
everybody because oh because honestly
like all the chat just looks like a
little
white little white squiggles yeah
man i'm gonna make another drink here in
a minute [ __ ] is so blind i'm so blind
i need to get some contact lenses i
don't have any like [ __ ]
see it that doesn't look too bad i guess
but it looked a lot better without it
i actually was i was really happy
because i did like the makeup this is
like
dude i do when i'm not reading i just
take it back off
i know but it's kind of a pain i just
like i always kind of feel like
i always kind of feel like when i can't
see like all the stuff is going on there
and i'm like i'm missing stuff
but um
no what was i going to say oh it took me
like it's this is so stupid like when i
did you remember other day when i did
the um when i did the uh the sugar skull
makeup
i seriously did that the first time and
it was like perfect and i was just kind
of like whoa go me right yeah and then
this one i said okay well i'm gonna do
kind of like a red queen type of
situation because i already had this
dress and i had read you know i've read
everything so i said that's not really
like a specific thing but i said i'm
going to do that do you know any [ __ ]
times it took me to get this goddamn
makeup right it says i do like five
times like maybe more than that i think
like five or six times like i kept
[ __ ] it up and i had to like take it
off
i was getting so frustrated
and i have a thing too where every now
and then i don't know if this is
allergies or whatever this is but i've
had it since i was a kid
is that
every now and then there'll be a day
when i wake up in one eye it's not
always the same one and one eye will
just not stop watering so like all so
all day i'll have like just
tears coming down like the corner of one
eye
so if i when i'm trying to put makeup on
you know it's
obviously like all the all the liner
will come off like in one corner it
looks really shitty and of course today
was one of those days so that didn't
help either so i'm like sitting there
trying to like blot it and then like put
powder over it and then it would water
again and i'm like god [ __ ] damn it
and then i'd put liner on it and the
liner would all rub off and i was
getting really frustrated luckily i
started really early so
because we weren't sure initially
because i said normally it's sunday and
we would do a matinee we would do it at
three but i was kind of like well it's
like i don't want to do one that early
because i wanted to like think of some
kind of costume to wear and i was like
well maybe we could do it at four
because then it would be like before
everybody goes trick-or-treating but
then tom's like yeah let's do it after
trick-or-treating because then we can
drink and we could have like kind of an
adult halloween party and i was like
yeah i guess so because it's not like we
had anywhere in particular to go tonight
so
that's that's that
i mean might watch some horror movies
later we watched carrie last night
actually because i just bought it on
blu-ray
and uh
i kind of wanted to watch midnight mass
the netflix series because everybody's
telling me about that and i got and i
got to go to the theater and see
last night in soho and i got to see
antlers
so
maybe we can go tomorrow
we'll see
or something i gotta i gotta go see them
you know what i mean
i kind of feel like i mean we could have
gone last night i suppose but
it probably would have been really
crowded
i said saw the paris hilton movie
yesterday i don't know what the paris
hilton movie the paris hilton movie
there was a paris hilton movie what the
one with uh was a house of wax are we
talking about the old one
come here
what's the matter pokemon in the room up
here she was mad because
because tom took her chair i took a
chair she was sleeping in the chair well
earlier she was sleeping on this
keyboard yeah so i was like i hate to
tell you this pookie but you're gonna
have to get your little fuzzy butt off
of there
i don't know i she really really likes
to sleep on keyboards she how do you
feel about it pope all your children
like yeah yeah too much room you know
they've taken up too much room
she only well she only likes to sit on
things if she knows that you want to sit
on it yeah it's not fun if you give her
her own thing even if it's the same
she's like well
no
i want to be in your way
that's that's the that's how she gets
enjoyment out of yeah see now she's
going down there like you gonna are you
gonna do on the treat thing t says she
saw last night in soho early today she
said you'll love it
it looked good i got yeah i thought it
looked really good and honestly like i
saw like in a facebook uh horror group
i'm in they said oh it was their the
best horror movie they'd seen this year
and uh so i'm i'm jacked it looks really
good
i i remember seeing the trailer like a
while back and i was just kind of like
yeah that looks pretty
red yeah alex hammond says that's a
great film based on the original house
of wax and tourist trap yeah that's that
yeah because paris hilton was in that
house of wax [ __ ] wasn't she
she gets i think she gets horribly
killed in it tina's saying check out my
boots yeah
new rocks
yeah yeah very expensive but they last
forever yeah
camp guys said
yeah
camp guy said jenny could win a jeopardy
daily double question on any horror
movie ever
probably not but
i don't know maybe
maybe
i've seen a lot of them
over the years
so i'd i'd give people a good run for
their money you don't pokey
yeah no need for me too says paris was
butchered through the face i do remember
that i do remember that yeah they're
commenting on what i'm wearing
let them see it yeah give us a spin doo
doo doo doo show us that ass
oh my god thank you hayden santos
how much money does youtube take from
the super chats
um not much because what what ends up
happening is that
it goes through google adsense
so usually you don't get the super chats
right away it's usually like um
the
what is it the 15th i think it's the
15th it's the 15th of the following
month and it just goes in with all your
google ad adsense money like all the
people that click on your
on your ads and stuff like that so they
just send you like a big lump sum no i'm
not pinhead man i'm [ __ ] uncle fester
[Laughter]
oh yeah you could have been pinhead that
would have taken a really long time
though
yeah i mean
yeah
it's sad because it's like i always have
i have stuff like that i could do that
yeah
i always like to do really elaborate
stuff for halloween but it's like we
just didn't have a lot of time this year
because like that's just my normal
clothes though well yeah you've just
worn that to the club
like that and it doesn't look festery
like when let's unless you're bald
so which you are now
yeah
but yeah i don't know like i was trying
to it's all velvet and brocade yeah it's
this is this was a dick jacket i'm gonna
take it off it sounded like you said a
dick jacket it's a dick jacket
your dick would dick and get so big you
got to make a special jacket
i have a jacket and also my dick has a
jacket it's a little it's a little
jacket
that's super cute
here's a here's a shirt that they will
like
look at those cuffs yeah see how they're
all pointy pointed cuffs
it's got pointed tails on it yeah see
fancy yeah pointed in the front don't
pull it up too much everybody will see
your little booty crack
your little hippie your little plumber
buddy
[Laughter]
uh tila says jenny is that a dress you
have on yes it is
um no need for me too said my youngest
daughter did velma from scooby doo we
saw actually we went to publix last
night to get halloween candy and we saw
the whole scooby gang yeah
they had the whole
they looked really good i thought didn't
see anybody else dressed up too much
last night i guess there was a lot of
parties going on but like i said you
know we didn't get to really go anywhere
but
you know um camp guy said i always
thought the normal niece on the monsters
was hot
yeah she was cute too yeah not really
not really my thing but you know
[Laughter]
i'm more of a mortification you bought
into carlo [ __ ] in her [ __ ] ivan
de carlo yeah yvonne de carl that's what
i said yeah
yvonne de carlo and her
lily munster outfit was looking hotter
than her though i think uh yeah yvonne
was pretty hot
she was indeed
and uh
i mean i kind of feel like well she when
she was on monster she was slightly
older she was like 40s yeah that's what
i thought
and she'd been in a [ __ ] ton of stuff
like prior to that yeah
but what are you doing down here folks
she's playing with all her little
halloween toys that that auntie ilsa
sent to her she loves that [ __ ] she
loves those toys she especially likes
that dracula one man she's really into
that dracula toy i think she likes him
because he's crinkly like when you push
her when she pushes her nose against it
goes
yeah
business says hell no i'm team marianne
okay
marilyn
that's her name right yeah yeah i think
it was it was marilyn oh my goodness so
you're like she was a misfit and ugly
that's so awesome well that's it that's
what i always loved about like adam's
family monsters it's just that i think
that's like a brilliant conceit and i
know yes that it came from charles adams
original cartoons but i thought it was
like a brilliant conceit that it's just
like this family of weirdos and they
think they're normal and everyone else
is weirdos because i'm like hey i can
relate so you know i think that's why it
kind of like resonated with people and i
liked too that especially on the addams
family i liked that they made them
really like happy
like they were happy being weirdos and
like they were super into it and they
didn't really get why other people were
like weirded out by them and i just
thought that was so funny the monsters
in the atoms family uh i read like
the the corporate sales pitch of what it
was they were trying to do with both of
them
and uh they were competitors those two
shows
it was
basically
made they were basically made for the
the california market when it came out
they knew that it would sell nationwide
but it was mostly marketed towards the
california market
and what it was is it was a story about
integration
that's what it was about it's about your
neighbors may not look like you but
they're regular people just like you
even
and that's what they're talking about
you're talking about so you're picking
on them goddammit they're basically
talking about people from mexico or
black people or whatever the people that
live next to you or they're from another
country that's a nice message though
that's yeah that's what it's about or
they may not be you know they may not
believe in the same things that you do
you know
that's what they're talking about
and it's all right yeah
well um
you have you got to look at 50s
television
50s television was real [ __ ]
government-backed it was kind of like
war propaganda it was all really about
uniformity
people coming back from the war trying
to recivilize these dudes that killed a
bunch of dudes in an apocalyptic fight
and trying to get them
in some kind of business like making
cars or advertisement sales or something
like that and get and get them married
and chilled out in suburbia
which means conformity
okay
so i guess people that you know really
weren't a part weren't really a part of
the war
we're kind of like there's a lot of
conformity going on you know that goes
all the way back to [ __ ] really
fathers knows best and all that [ __ ] you
know
not everybody is the same
so that's what those that's what those
series were about
yeah and those shows i kind of feel like
people uh look back at those fondly as
it was some kind of golden age i'm like
yeah but those shows were not even back
then that wasn't really what actual most
real people's lives were
and i love lucy
bewitched
and i dream of genie
we're about mixed marriages
that's that's exactly what that was
about even though i don't think i feel
like that wouldn't even register with
people nowadays
well actually it didn't even register
with me in the 80s like and i used to
see i love lucy on like you know on
cable and stuff yeah and um
it honestly that it honestly never
occurred to me yeah your wife she's not
around here and she's got these
weird-ass relatives they keep showing up
to your [ __ ] house you just want her
to be normal but she can't be that's not
in her nature
that's exactly about what
that's what they're again i can relate
yeah they're talking about race and
culture
yeah it's just like being funny they're
talking about race and culture there's
what they're talking about
and uh i love lucy was the was
switched around desi you know desi was
from from cube from cuba you know yeah
and a lot of people don't realize it but
then you know [ __ ] desires and
lucille ball
and you know the i love lucy show is
about an interracial relationship yeah
that's that's what it is
yeah we today you wouldn't think that
hispanics are you know
a different race that's what i mean like
i said ethnic group in the 80s that
literally never occurred to me yeah or
that's what it was
it just it just didn't i don't know it
just didn't register that they were
different races yeah i don't know
and he spoke spanish and [ __ ] yeah which
like i said i was just kind of like
okay and i haven't and i grew up in like
kind of a rednecky area but even in the
rednecky area i grew up in they didn't
know people didn't notice it it has to
do with that yeah it has to do with how
it's presented yeah
and you know ricky was a a cool dude he
was a good-looking dude and he you know
[ __ ] was an entertainer and you know
based on desi arnaz he's you know it was
basically kind of like desi arne's
playing himself you know it's kind of
how he that's that was that that was his
background also
so uh you know he was approved of and
that opened the door for you know
integration
ethnic integration and racial
integration
i think we had a little hiccup which had
been going that had been going on anyway
it's just that uh
hollywood and television at the time was
kind of like uh
the approval mechanism to normalize it
if you saw it on tv it was okay even
danny said so
[Laughter]
see he saw it on the television
they knew what they were doing
cannibalism cannibalism
it's okay
[Laughter]
where do you want to go pope no she's
just pretending like
she's like no
she hasn't been freaking out too much
like for all the doorbell ringing and
stuff like that she keeps like sitting
up and being like what's all that noise
she knows it's not a normal day
she's used to seeing us dress like
weirdos though so she didn't even like
she didn't even bat an eyelid
um let's see uh yeah tila said all those
movies back then with names like them it
came from outer space lol yeah fear of
the other yeah that's honestly like h.p
lovecraft built his whole entire [ __ ]
career out of that
of disguising his hatred for people who
weren't
him as like various other monsters
plural hp
he was so
he had to stick so far up his butt
uh you know sheltered dude uh yeah a
little bit he's a fascinating character
but um you know and he wrote some
awesome [ __ ] but lovecraft was he had
some issues lovecraft was racist against
white people he was racist against
pretty much everybody right that wasn't
him yeah that wasn't from like
descended from english royalty
yeah yeah
you're not english you're not you're not
an anglo oh [ __ ] you're you're from
ireland oh you beast well yeah because
well it's weird because it's weird to
think about now because like i said
everyone's like english irish what's the
damn difference but um you know well
nowadays but like back then the irish
were considered like way not
like almost like a different race too
which is crazy
bad history there read up about all that
[ __ ] yeah that's insane well even when
they first came here
yeah you know what i mean yeah a lot of
people [ __ ] don't realize that the
[ __ ] ink
at the irish
the irish when they came here were
basically slaves basically
a lot of them were well like indentured
servants like a lot of them some of them
like essentially sold themselves into
labor like to get passage over here the
difference between an african slave is
that an african slave is worth money
okay
and irishman wouldn't wear [ __ ]
he was like a debt like ah
i mean they were [ __ ] they they meant
it when like you know no dogs and no
irish allowed
um
because they didn't speak english
most of them when they showed up here
they spoke gaelic and they were just
described if you see how they were
described in the newspapers of the time
little monkey men
whose men were were good friend
whose men were good for nothing but
crime and their women good for nothing
but prostitution
that's literally what they were [ __ ]
saying about
that uh when they were around you had to
[ __ ] nail everything down they'd
steal everything
uh they'd drink the place [ __ ] dry
they'd fall that's true
knife people and shoot people at the
drop of a hat that they were all just
ran around in gangs
and there was probably a lot of truth to
it
at the time
but um
one of the priorities now if you look
you know i don't know if you any people
who are not americans who are listening
if if you actually look
at the demographics and studies that
have been done
it's some kind of like amazing
percentage that well first of all there
are more people of irish descent in the
united states than there are in ireland
i think there might be yeah they are
they they
when they got here they grew like weeds
um
they also um
uh none of almost none of them carry
irish last names because it was a
priority to change your name to an
english last name as quickly as you
could to try to get rid of any kind of
irish
heritage in you you didn't want to carry
that with you because it was like a
stigma
uh so there's just and then they i saw a
[ __ ] study that was done they said
that there's something incredible like
70 percent of all caucasians in the
united states are mostly irish
when it comes i believe that with their
genetic makeups well there was a massive
uh immigration of them yeah
and they just took over they were
especially during the 1800s in the very
early 1900s
they were kind of like
the illegal immigrants of the day kind
of like these people come from central
and south america they just [ __ ]
flooded the united states with them
and not for good reasons it was just to
use them up and most of them didn't live
if you actually look at the
look at the history what happened to
them most of them didn't didn't survive
one generation most of them didn't
reproduce
along those railroad lines they'll find
even to this day mass graves with
[ __ ] thousands of dead irish i'll
[ __ ] shout out with bullet holes and
right along with them chinese
and with no explanation
and no i i can imagine what the
explanation probably is yeah and people
don't realize that in those days
corporations were [ __ ] more powerful
than the government and they probably
still are now
but um the railroads of the 1800s had
the power
to to to sentence employees to death
yeah pretty much they had their own they
had their own courts they had their own
private armies following the [ __ ]
construction crews if there was any
labor problems they [ __ ] mowed them
down
and just buried them and
buried him [ __ ] the hell was he
wanting to get paid enough to like pay
rent [ __ ] you
there's no telling what what happened
there was just some kind of labor
uprisings probably working dudes near to
death or not paying them on time
uh [ __ ] fights breaking out that
turned into [ __ ] race wars between
irish and chinese and then [ __ ] you
know they just shot a [ __ ] a [ __ ] ton of
them to quell the riot
and a lot of them
yes there's all kinds of [ __ ] that
happened
back in the 1800s and even even the
1900s
that people of today just wouldn't
believe you know they're like
corporations sentencing people to death
yeah
well yeah they had a [ __ ] ton of money
so yeah the whole story of the
pankertons would probably blow a lot of
people's minds we still need to do a
show about that yeah i keep putting it
in the poll but it never wins today you
got cia and fbi
and maybe like
contractors and then intelligence
contractors
in the 1800s they didn't have even a
secret service that was all done by the
pinkertons which was a private mercenary
group
and they hired
anyone who was talent
including women
uh if they were prostitutes that could
talk their way into a man's pants they'd
hire him they'd [ __ ] um they
assassinated people they [ __ ] hunted
people down they [ __ ] toppled enemy
corporations inside the united states
that was a threat to somebody just they
did all kinds of weird [ __ ] they
protected the president
they protected [ __ ] gold shipments
they did all kinds of [ __ ] they were
mercenaries
but they were in the blueprint for the
cia
cia fbi and the secret service
yeah because they didn't really have
that they didn't have that then so they
used these guys
and uh a [ __ ] like half of them were
would today would be considered because
convicted felons
because a lot of the talent was guys
that [ __ ] got in trouble and [ __ ]
did prison time and they had special
talents and they'd go to work for
pigettons
this whole thing deal like we don't hire
felons oh no they were seeking them out
because they were the boba fetts of
their day you want you want boba fett if
you want if you need boba fett you look
you're looking for boba fett you're not
looking for um
uh some boy scout
and that's what [ __ ] it's just badass
stories of from
a time gone past a time past and a time
that will probably return because
everything's cyclical you know the
contracting scene of the [ __ ] past 20
30 years has gotten kind of hairy it's
kind of weird
because it involves foreigners foreign
contractors doing stuff for the united
states on the slick and [ __ ]
um
been going on for a long time i mean
my favorite movie [ __ ] predator one a
lot of people are saying oh man [ __ ]
you know dutch and his crew of special
forces guys no
go back and pay attention that's not
special forces they're mercenaries
it's a mercenary rescue team they don't
[ __ ] and there's rules for
mercenaries
but no they're all ex-special forces
guys
uh ex-special forces guys on a mission
to rescue special forces guys which
that's real that does
happen john smith says by the way the
people who live in ireland hate it when
people in the us say they are irish yeah
they do um and i can see that because
they're like look you weren't born in
ireland you've never been here so [ __ ]
off with that [ __ ] i get it you're
the descendants of the irish yeah
they're yeah they're of irish descent
but yeah if you weren't born there and
you've never been there
then yeah i don't go around saying
you're irish because you ain't
i feel like if you were born here
you're american you know wherever you
are yeah but yeah
well yeah but i mean you can say that
you descended oh you know my parents
were from wherever that's fine but it's
just kind of like if you like i said if
you've never
even been there yeah that seems like a
little weird to say
a lot of america's history is forgotten
and it's not taught on purpose
the first real badass president that we
had the one that helped carve the empire
out was andrew jackson
and he was the nation's first
irish-american president
and when he got the presidency people
thought it was the end of the [ __ ]
world he had huge parties out in front
of the white house where he was giving
out free whiskey and all the [ __ ]
irish would show up they were drunk out
in front of a white house lawn
he was dueling dudes to the death and
shooting him [ __ ] with pistols and
[ __ ] he but he was actually quite
sensible
he's a lot more sensible than people you
can read his writings and things that he
said and
uh laws that he passed it made sense at
the time
but during the time of andrew jackson
the for the first time the american
army's ranks swelled to to a power that
were to be reckoned with and it's
because
who is joining the army at that time all
those irishmen
because they now had an irish president
so now you had an irish president and an
irish army
their battle flags were blue battle
flags with irish symbols on them like
harps and [ __ ] clovers and all this
kind of irish stuff and that worried a
lot of people who weren't irish
but they didn't really know much about
american history how america was gonna
unfold later on too
because
not too long after that
and kind of like uh i guess it was the
1870s 1880s around that time most of the
american army were native americans
mo and most of them were um
um
uh what was it what was the name of
lakota
if you look if you look at pictures of
the american cavalry from the late 1800s
it's all lakota braves in
american uniforms and everything and
back in
washington dc they were [ __ ] scared
they were afraid can we trust these guys
are they really americans yeah
yeah
it's just that you know it got to the
point where they couldn't hunt buffalo
because property rights were happening
there was trains running around
i mean and in in the lakota
lakota
culture it was a macho culture where men
were hunters and warriors they couldn't
really hunt like they used to because
agriculture was coming in the only thing
they could do
to be a warrior was to join the united
states army and they still did it today
to to this day you know when i was in
the army you just indian native
americans were just overrepresented
there's more men there than there are
than there are percentages of native
americans in the u.s population and it's
because they have that in their culture
is that you have to be
a warrior and the only way to do it in
the united states is to join the us army
yeah so they're in there lots of them
and they're good dudes
so
what i'm saying is is that they worried
about the irish they worried about the
indians they worried about all these
little ethnic groups people are always
worried about you're worried about
worrying about [ __ ] yeah because you're
not they're not they're worried about
black people too they're like these
people are not really loyal to the
united states maybe we shouldn't give
them guns you know what i mean
we shouldn't let them have horses
uh but
it was uh
they still kind of do it today maybe we
shouldn't let these people have guns
a lot of it had to do with the south you
know what i mean because northerners
just they just don't trust southerners i
don't blame them you know there's a lot
of bad blood there
over time and it's just
when i was up in when i was living in
the new england area there's just a big
cultural difference
and
when they found out when they find out
you're southern they just don't look at
you exactly the same
and it's just their culture you know
california not so bad but
well i mean the same thing is true of
california that's true of florida in
that you get people from all over the
country moving there yeah so it's almost
like you don't really have
in in pockets you do they like have one
big overriding culture but because
they're it's such diverse you know like
i said so so many people move there for
various reasons you don't really get the
this kind of like insular yeah kind of
thing that you would maybe get like in a
smaller although here's something else
i've mentioned before and it was
reconfirmed to be hanging out this biker
bar where i'm going in there and start
making local friends and [ __ ] with these
bikers
um
one third of them are from um
the north or california that have moved
here
and they're more so they're trying to be
more southern than me they're trying to
out southern my ass they're like
they're like converts to it
they've like converted to a new religion
yeah it's always those are always the
most overzealous yeah yeah
and now it's been happening for
centuries too
like uh southern plantation owners
were living in the south but they tended
to come from the north because they had
the money to start plantations
so just because
you were in the south didn't mean that's
where you came from and just because
the the northerner cost the ones that
would come here [ __ ] took to southern
culture like a [ __ ] duck to water
the ones that come here they come in
here for a reason
they didn't like where they came from
so like oh we like it here
and then they try to out southern you
you know it's funny it is cute you know
what i mean
but you just they're trying to you know
trying to i know you're a yankee you
know what i mean [ __ ] you got to [ __ ]
with them
because then they buy you beer
you know i know you're a yankee
just [ __ ] like that well [ __ ] man if i
go i'm gonna pull rank on you because i
was actually born in the south and you
weren't i wasn't actually born here no
you were born in california [ __ ] yeah i
was born right here yeah in good old
redneck florida yeah but they were i was
only born over there because the
military my parents were the military
service though
okay they were southern that's his story
they were southern
uh dallas from mississippi and i grew up
there too
well yeah like i said my dad's side of
the family is from tennessee actually
they they moved down in the 50s yeah
when my dad was actually mother's
family's from virginia they weren't from
california
california in that era everybody was
moving out there yeah so yeah it's my
dad's side yeah my dad's out of family
like i said my my dad
was born
he was born in tennessee but he moved to
florida when he was four because my
grandparents moved here in 1958
and my mom's side of the family are from
maryland yeah so uh and they moved down
i think it's also in the 50s now that
i'm thinking about it
uh danny rolling ghostface says that
jacket is giving off a lollipop illusion
effect
yeah so your head looks like a lollipop
and that's like the buttons or the stick
i'm guessing that's what he's talking
about now terrace is in there giving
[ __ ] andrew jackson his [ __ ] bert
his heritage his birthright everything
where his parents came from he was scots
irish
that's right and his parents where they
were from there from ulster and
um
which you can read it if you want to
but uh yeah
most
most caucasians of the day are basically
scotch irish in german with some french
and english
i mean depending on what part of the
country but i mean largely
i mean like i said the there was a
massive like irish immigration into the
us right and our our
our latinos are [ __ ] super diverse
they could be central america or south
american or brazilian they're
a lot of them are at least half european
mixed with
some mesoamerican and possibly some
african uh with also some germanic in
them and then you have mexicans who are
mesoamerican with some spanish and now
there a lot of them are like what our
friend kaley who passed i showed you
video of where it's you know because
where you know they're they're kind of
like half scotch irish parent along with
a kind of like a you know a latino
parent
and
they're just like any other american you
know i mean you don't
it doesn't really matter because i think
like i knew you didn't think of her as
me i kind of i knew her for a long time
before i realized that she was like half
mexican half mexican yeah well that's
why she was so little but she was so
cute a little cute yeah i think she's a
little bigger that's bumming me out all
over yeah she's yeah but what happened
to her was bad
yeah yeah that sucked yeah but no we a
lot as i was saying that's it i said it
before in earlier shows you know they
said well man it's very hispanic in
florida it always was this was part of
the spanish empire it was always half
it was always half latino
and then everything in between where it
mixes
and it always had a black population
than it also always and it's in the
no matter who comes and goes the
seemingly according to the records
the mix or the proportions was about the
same it's just that there's a lot more
people now
that's that's yeah because like i said
to be honest with you even when i was
like in elementary school in middle
school like in the 70s and 80s um i
remember [ __ ] being like pretty diverse
you know we had most of the us it was
yeah we had like latinos we had um you
know kids from india we had all kind of
different stuff and like i said we and i
grew up in like not really that big a
city just kind of like a rednecky sort
of
people from india were rare though when
i was a kid that's like a new phenomenon
people from india
but i tell you people that come here
from india man they [ __ ] love it they
don't want to go back to india
they just love it here run into them all
the time
i was the white man they'd run to to ask
them if the bears were gonna gonna eat
them remember that [ __ ] happened then
she was [ __ ] funny
remember when that happened everybody's
worried i was walking i was walking
along the [ __ ] path and the [ __ ]
indian kid comes running up on me on a
bx bmx bike dude there's a bear down
there's a bear down there sir is there
just a bear it's gonna be all right they
won't eat us no they won't eat you yeah
they're not that kind of thing yeah no
right now just back there it'll be all
right it won't eat you it'll run
although i have to say so our old
neighborhood um they gave everybody
those bear safe cans yeah um this new
neighborhood doesn't happen doesn't have
them but they got bears and uh so a
couple of times we put the garbage out
and then the next morning the garbage is
like all over the place yeah
[ __ ] so the bear is like driving around
driving around bear's driving around
that'd be something bear drive digging
or being taken around in there yeah it
wouldn't shock me honestly it wouldn't
shock me if i saw a drive a bear drive
it around
they could do a lot of things i was
going to say that uh one of the things
about um
well it's kind of like the big irish
immigration and everything like that
that might be one of the things that
because they're that's kind of where the
whole halloween thing came from yeah and
so that's why although ironically it's a
lot bigger now than it used to be but i
remember
when um i was going back and forth to
the uk like back in the 90s
and they had halloween there but it
wasn't like a big deal like in the u.s
it's a big [ __ ] deal it's like second
only to like christmas yeah like people
spend billions of dollars there's
parties everywhere it's this big huge
thing it's soloing but it's like an
americanized yeah but i feel like in the
uk it's still not really
that big of a deal i haven't been there
in a in a while it's a big deal though
now japan japan loves halloween
they're taking that treat and they're
wearing [ __ ] halloween costumes all
right you go you're going yeah japan
loves it why not it's fun japanese loves
anything where you're dressing up yeah
i've seen some weird [ __ ] where they
they don't know much about christmas or
christian they don't really know there's
no difference between santa claus and
jesus that much really and they know
that they're the man they know that
there's a santa claus and trees and then
they know that there's nativity scenes
but i saw one japanese uh scene where
they had
the nativity scene and in the nativity
scene was a crucifix and crucified on
the [ __ ] cross with santa
i've heard about that see i thought that
was an urban legend because i thought
that was an urban legend that's been
going around since the 80s no it was in
japan they had that but they had seen
yeah it might be yeah i've heard
yeah but like i said i don't i mean
that's fine i mean christmas like i said
if you want to celebrate christmas you
don't have to be a christian i'm not so
it's like you know and i i love
christmas yeah you know [ __ ] it it's
just celebrate whatever you want and you
can celebrate it however you want if you
just want to take those yeah we're just
going to do a tree and presents and [ __ ]
like that to [ __ ] do that no one's
you know there's no [ __ ] christmas
police there's no halloween police i
know some people get all [ __ ] head up
about it i was uh i was reading another
article too that they were asking like
what age did you stop trick-or-treating
and she's asking for the green ones okay
i'm gonna open them up look at her face
she's like looking up like
oh girl open it up
she likes to switch out like between the
catnip and the and the tasty human it
goes right to the box she wants and
starts pawing it and she's yeah the
green one's like here this one
she asks for the flavor that she wants
i guess she's like looking like
i'm coming right out of there you go
there i poured like little piles of
treats like all over this office and
it's like she'll eat one or two and then
she leaves a bunch of crumbs i gotta
come out here and vacuum i know she's
leaving
a really good carpet shampoo
but i was you know so yeah so i was
reading this article about you know what
age did you stop trick-or-treating and
i'm just kind of like
you know there's always like a couple
curmudgeons on there curmudgeons that
are always kind of like yeah halloween's
just for kids just like oh christmas
just don't go to the club man [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off our club seems sexy as [ __ ] for
halloween that's what i mean we didn't
go this year don't let like why it
doesn't mean like just because you're an
adult that doesn't mean like you have to
like [ __ ] you can't have any [ __ ]
joy in your life anymore [ __ ] that [ __ ]
the funny thing is about the japanese
though is that that from what i saw on
youtube they they mis understood certain
concepts but they understood the concept
of halloween which is let's dress up in
these scary costumes and go around have
fun and go to the club and really that's
all halloween that's and the more people
want to embrace that concept like i said
it makes me really really happy
that
halloween is now second only to
christmas like i said people spend
billions and billions of dollars
and i like now because when i was
growing up like halloween was a big deal
but
it was mostly a kid thing like you know
the kids and you go trick-or-treating
and get candy and blah blah
you know they had parties and stuff but
i feel like it wasn't as widespread now
it's like you see adults dressed up like
all the time and it's like not that
weird so
like i said what's why not
like it's just because you're an adult
doesn't mean you have to be like a
miserable old [ __ ] you could just have a
good you just have a good time no one's
no one's gonna like
take your adult card away
like i said there's there's no fun
police
so you know you can just do what you
want just be just
do some silly [ __ ] we had teenagers
coming
um trick or treating today
and um
one of them was a
dude he's probably 16
with his 15 year old girlfriend he's
dressed up as i don't know a big banana
i think it's a big old banana
and then his little 15 year old
girlfriend was dressed up in this
[ __ ]
little po peep costume or something with
[ __ ] high stockings and skimpy as
[ __ ] and i almost said something i was
like
never mind tom was gonna dab out for a
second
are you old enough to be wearing that
young lady you know
too old to be dressed all that skimpy or
too young to be dressed all that skimpy
like that that belongs in the club you
know but i didn't want to say anything
to her well the thing about it though i
have to say that there's not if you're
buying a costume like off the rack yeah
a women's costume and i noticed this
like when i look online and pretty much
95 of the women's costumes are sexy
something right yeah you can't just buy
like a normal i mean you can but it's
not as
i think it was a little red riding hood
oh yeah
that little red riding hood or something
maybe it was and i was just going uh
[Music]
if i was your dad you would not be out
i don't know i don't have a problem like
obviously you don't want to see an 11
year old girl run around in that [ __ ]
that would be a little weird but um
i don't know i feel like if you're a
teenager
it's probably i don't know i don't have
kids so i don't it's hard for me to say
it's not advisable probably because
there's a lot of perverts out there but
this is a higher ed neighborhood once
you get to like 15 or 16 i'm not gonna
like say anything about right like i
said it'd be different if they were like
11. that would she knew what she was
doing that's well yeah
i mean you know she was trolling the
neighborhood her and her boyfriend they
were trolling yeah banana man and
[ __ ] banana look like a man banana
man and [ __ ] little boy or whatever
little red riding hood
i kind of feel like i don't you know
what if you
made if you put the effort into a
costume
and you want to trick or treat i don't
give a [ __ ] if you're 80 years old if
you got a costume on you can have some
candy
yeah it's halloween's fun it's for
everybody that's it's a free candy thing
like i said you're making an effort now
don't like show up at the door just
[ __ ]
in your just regular ass clothes
that's that's lame
but if you have a costume on i'm not
gonna like i'm not i'm not mad about it
yeah
do you guys know that song um my sister
put it on a halloween mix for me a long
time ago
uh it's like a like a psychobilly song
it's called no costume no candy by the
swinging neck breakers
and uh it's super funny so he's like
laying out his philosophy and like
pretty much you know as long as you have
a costume on you can have candy but if
you don't
he's like showing up like looking like
burglars with flashlights a pillow case
like no constant one that he's like not
gonna he's not gonna get medicated
talking about night of the living dead
camp guy said i never touched a ouija
board even as a kid i was afraid to fool
with it theresa rayborn [ __ ] posted
all those facts i guess to correct me
that he was not irish america he was not
irish american his parents were from
ireland which yes he was irish american
yeah she just confirmed what i said
yeah
but go back and read the descriptions of
the time
it didn't matter where you were born
okay if you had descended from the irish
in the 1800s you were irish
that's just the way they saw you that's
why they were all trying to change their
last names
but if memory serves second um jackson
was like one of the few guys that
[ __ ] kind of like embraced his
[ __ ] irish heritage and his the army
the armies of irish that joined up in
the us army started to happen there's
paintings of it
them out there [ __ ] fighting and
doing [ __ ]
uh with these big old blue flags with
harps on them and four leaf clovers and
uh just stuff from irish culture they
were they were big into that at that
time
america was damn irish powered they were
the ones that were doing everything
they were [ __ ]
working them boys to death
but you know they had a
they were doing it for the promise of
riches and a better life
they didn't have that back in
ireland
nothing going on there good old potato
famine yeah
which reminds me again i was reading
something again earlier because i've
been reading halloween [ __ ] all day so i
was reading something earlier about this
i think it was on facebook somebody said
they just heard about this guy
who was giving out
freshly baked potatoes
to people for halloween like he would
put it in the bag like with tongs then
he's like hey you want like some i got
sour cream like in little cups and stuff
like that
and i'm like
that's
logistically that's kind of [ __ ] up
but i was like honest but on the other
hand that's actually pretty awesome i
would like a baked potato for halloween
please that'd be delicious
yeah we didn't eat very much today
well you know yeah i'll get some i'll
get us some food later well later yeah
like i said it's almost nine so i don't
think we're probably not gonna get any
more trick-or-treaters
how much candy do we have left a bunch
but it's almost all um snickers
i don't have a problem with that i saved
like eight snickers is like my favorite
i snake i saved like eight wrists peanut
butter cups the singles okay you know
yeah we went to publix last night and
they didn't have a lot of
candy i mean they had some but they
didn't have like a lot to pick from
but
they had like they had the good [ __ ]
still yeah it's expensive
we just didn't get a chance to go to
sam's because like i said now we moved
out here like sam's is kind of like a
lot farther away it's not really worth
it to go down there unless you're gonna
get a bit a big a large amount of stuff
and yeah and the thing about it is that
had we went to sam's and got like that
big [ __ ] 10 pound bag of candy or
whatever it's like we would have had all
that candy left over
and yeah it probably would have been the
same because i think we spent
how much was it i think the the littler
bags were the snickers was 11.99 and
that's like a bigger bag and then they
had a smaller bags of kit kats and
reese's peanut butter cups and i think
those were 5.99 or 6.99 something like
that
but
that's i guess because we waited till
the last minute and was like we went to
publix and they just had like one little
cap
with you know they're already starting
to put all their thanksgiving [ __ ] man
that's like that's depressing to me
you know
i mean i just well i guess i kind of
feel like this year because we were
moving and like there was so much other
stuff going on i usually like to do like
big lead up to halloween and i know i
did a lot of um you know reviews for the
show and everything like that so that
was fun but
i don't know like i said i usually like
to have more time to like think of a
costume or like buy a costume and it's
like this year i didn't really have
enough money to do that so i was kind of
like trying to
you know work with [ __ ] i already had
and
i don't know so and then like now it's
halloween and it's like always get
bummed out like the day after halloween
because it's over
i'm like man now i gotta wait till
[ __ ] next year cause it's my favorite
it's my favorite holiday i like
thanksgiving and christmas too not
saying that actually looking forward to
thanksgiving because
man all that food
[Laughter]
i'm gonna have to starve up until then
i'm going to starve for the next month
so i can eat a lot
yeah
let's get some pumpkins
yeah we didn't get any pumpkins either i
didn't even carve a pumpkin i carved a
couple last year
but this year
yeah we go well
actually now they're probably there's a
pumpkin patch yeah
only a mile or two from here yeah
um
and they might be getting rid of all
their [ __ ] because they're like oh
halloween's over nobody's gonna buy the
[ __ ] now although no no we got you got
halloween you got christmas
well you can make
thanksgiving well yeah like i said but i
kind of feel like most people buy
pumpkins for halloween right so they can
like make but we'll go in there and look
i bet you they still have them
yeah i'm sure they do yeah because [ __ ]
man those i'm gonna make some like
pumpkin pies out of that [ __ ] get a good
deal on spawn make some curry pumpkin
soup yeah
i can make all kinds of pumpkin stuff
man yeah we've said that before man it's
like just those two pumpkins soup
pumpkin curry man we made chicken curry
i made pumpkin bread
actually i made a i made that a bunch of
times yep just out of like two kind of
decent-sized pumpkins we made so much
stuff i got to get some buckets those
buckets i had were gone oh you threw
those out yeah
i mean no i didn't i didn't throw them
out i'm i'm uh
i'm uh storing dry beans in them oh okay
i gotcha i got a bunch of pinto beans in
there
might be time to rotate those pinto
beans though
yeah
i'll make some uh bean
refried bean filling
and freeze the rest of it yeah i'll
probably do that tila says halloween
decorations and candy all half off
tomorrow y'all yeah oh yeah
you know what though here's the thing
and this is going back to what i was
saying about halloween being like a
massive [ __ ] deal in the u.s
is that i watch a lot of those um you
know halloween decor haul videos like
jade the libra and voltaire does them
and stuff like that
and
one thing that i've noticed is that when
they go around to all the places they
usually go like joanne's and michael's
and spirit halloween and like all the
norman home goods and all those kind of
places they're like you really have to
get there early in the season
because there's a whole subculture of
people
that
know like keeps track of whatever lines
of halloween products are coming out
that year and it's like as soon as they
put the [ __ ] on the shelves they go in
there and get it
so
you really have to they'll put on their
website it's like you know this is the
line that we have this year we have this
that and the other thing and people will
just be waiting and they'll keep going
back to the store is it out yet is it
out yet is it out yet and it's not but
then like the second it comes out it
sells out so
i didn't realize that there's that many
people
that are like so into like collecting
all the hot but i mean that's awesome
i'm just i just didn't know that there
was that it was that much of a thing
that it sells out every year and because
like i said jade the libra she usually
stops doing the decor videos sort of
halfway into october she's like because
by that time like everything's been
cleaned out everything's just like
everybody's bought everything and
there's nothing good left it's just
really kind of picked over which uh is
crazy but like i said i like that i like
i like that everybody's like super
annoying
uh who uh
um
i'm good friends with volunteers ex-wife
tanya he seems like a nice man voldemort
yeah
yeah
tanya was crazy but i love tommy your
time is [ __ ] funny
done her name was tonya fournier
she was this uh
girl that worked for chanel
she's like a model this is back in the
day when we were up in boston
and uh she was
pen pals and like uh
this famous dude that we had back in the
day had a huge crush on her he ended up
being from that band [ __ ]
was that blonde dude's name that was
constantly in [ __ ]
probably
uh [ __ ] what james koviak oh yeah yeah
yeah that's his name his name is koviak
he was like this super hot goth dude
that all the [ __ ] goth girls were
[ __ ] chasing after john koviak yeah i
remember those pictures
those pictures were like iconic yeah
so john koviak was all into her
and then uh they didn't live near each
other though they were writing letters
and [ __ ]
and uh
the voltaire thing happened after i
[ __ ] left boston so i didn't know
that was going on then i found out later
that those two had gotten married
voltaire
it's funny though and then they got
divorced
i ran into voltaire up here in orlando
he was [ __ ] up the dj booth a friend
of mine and i said i said voltaire man
nice to meet you bro he says i'm a
friend i'm a friend of tanya's he's like
tiny fournier yeah that's my girlfriend
back in boston man i was looking
nice to meet you and he's like yeah yeah
where is she is like i don't know where
she is she's you know actually
actually i think i think i did know
where she was i think she was in uh
arizona
i think she went back to arizona
yeah
yeah but yeah voltaire um he has
because like i said he's a musician
obviously and he was an animator for a
long time too
so his music is like actually really fun
like really entertaining
and so he still plays live shows but
yeah he has a whole [ __ ] channel
that's essentially like a gothic
homemaking channel where he decorates
various rooms in his tiny tiny new york
apartment
um he has a house in mexico city too i
think
and uh he does halloween haul videos
he's done a couple crossovers with jade
the libra because they know each other
um so because i guess he's played at oh
here's another thing that bummed me out
i was just watching this uh because i
watched every time jade the libra put
something out i usually watch her
what ended up happening with her is that
her husband
um owned a club in kansas city i can't
remember what the name of it was but i
guess voltaire used to play there all
the time and that's kind of how they
knew each other i think
but
they had to end up closing
and they'd been they'd run that club for
like 12 years 13 years like some
ridiculous amount of time and um it was
really really sad that they had to end
up closing it so
i saw the video where she was talking
about that i'm like oh man that's like a
[ __ ] bummer so i don't really know
what's gonna happen with that now
and uh so you know that's kind of a
shame she's talking about how uh you
know that
um what's his name that uh [ __ ] um oh
[ __ ]
the voltaire is a handsome man this is
the guy i was talking about this is john
koviak this is the other one no sorry
that was back in the day yeah i think
you've shown that picture before yeah
but not her
that was john koviak that was like uh
in the 90s that was like the main goth
poster boy
yeah like i said he was in propaganda
all the time yeah trying to get the
pigeon
yeah voltaire he's got to be
well he's older than you that's for sure
yeah he's 55.
yeah you wouldn't know it looking at him
he's in good shape
and um
and he's fun he's funny because i like
that he's just unabashedly
into spooky [ __ ] and halloween [ __ ] and
he's into dad jokes and it's just kind
of like and he's just totally not he's
just real unapologetic about it and i
just think that's really charming
um he does a lot of videos with his uh
fiance what is her name
[ __ ] she's a little japanese woman
i can't remember what her name is but
they've been doing a lot of videos
together like lately and she's super
cute they do a lot of their haul videos
together
but
i really i don't know there's something
kind of fascinating about and i guess
there's been like an explosion of them
in the last few years because because i
watched the jade the libra ones and the
voltaire ones so i get all these
recommendations for like hey all these
other halloween hauls and i was just
kind of like
man i want to watch all those but god
damn
because honestly they're all kind of
going to the same stores so
you know all the stores kind of have the
same
thing so if you've seen one person's
then you've seen all the other ones
you know that was tanya
that's actually i think kind of recent
of her actually
that's what she look like okay
that's voltaire's ex-wife
yeah tammy says uh he was gonna do a
travel show and talk about unusual
cultures but cove it happened yeah i
think he had well i don't think it was
for netflix but he had some kind of
thing where
um he was gonna go all over the but he
does do like on his youtube channel one
of my favorite things that he did was
that he went around the world
and went to
different monster themed bars like he
was trying to do
and he kind of succeeded i guess he
wanted to do like he wanted to find a
restaurant or bar or something like that
somewhere in the world that was themed
around a particular universal monster
and he wanted to do like all of them and
he did pretty good i thought like so he
had he found like a mommy one and a
wolfman one and all this other and like
i said they were in countries you
wouldn't necessarily associate
with that like one was like in the
philippines and like there was you know
it was just like crazy but that's i
really really liked that because i
really like it when people go whole hog
into the [ __ ]
monster themed bars man i love that kind
of [ __ ] tila's first name is tanya
didn't know that
i feel like for a long time she was
cagey about telling us
[Laughter]
yeah terry said uh yeah i could see him
doing that he's really engaging it goes
to out-of-the-way places i like too that
he's um
he seems real supportive of um
kind of like
local artists and stuff like that like
he always uh seems to kind of go to
their shops i particularly like i said
he does a lot of stuff in uh mexico
because he has a house in mexico city
and um
the couple of goth stores that he went
there
uh went to there there's a bunch of them
there
what's the matter pool now she wants
someone out of the black box she's like
i would like the tasty humans so now you
want the tasty human ones okay she like
i think she likes to taste the human
ones better but she likes to switch them
out maybe she uh
forgot what color was what
did you forget that the green ones were
not tasty human
see that's what i thought earlier yeah
she's looking at me like do it
open it what's taking so long open it
come here
she's like i wish i could open it but i
can't open it she does try to open it
but she can't get it all the way out
here they are she's just like looking
yeah
you're doing it from afar huh but you
don't understand it
what no
here it is
pookie's like you understand it pookie's
constant
facial expression is one of like abject
surprises she's like what
what yeah yeah what is happening right
now that's what happened
you're so crazy yeah
that's all yeah goofing around aren't
you yeah she's a girl you're goofing
around aren't you
there they are right there she's like uh
she's like
what you saw it you saw it happen it's
right here you're smart pokey come on
this one here and this one there
two piles see that one and that one
there you go she's like no i'm not just
confused
[Laughter]
oh poor pookie
she's planning ahead
yeah because once one thing
one thing that she does
yeah no she looked at it and then she
walked by she's planning ahead yeah
that's she does she likes to have cause
like i said we leave some treats for her
on like a little dish yeah like before
we go to bed
and if there aren't enough there
she kind of like will come up like on
the bed and be like burp yeah she'll run
over there and then run over there and
like stand by it and be like uh there's
not enough treats on here to like last
me through the night i don't want to
have to wake you [ __ ] up yeah
so and then you put them there and then
she doesn't eat them no she just looks
and just be like okay that's acceptable
yep and then she runs off it's what's so
[ __ ] funny
is that over the day the pile will get
smaller and smaller
but they will almost
almost never will they be totally empty
they'll always be one
she'll leave one left
yeah because just in case just in case
like i'm not going to get any more
yeah i'm just gonna
she is very plan ahead yeah at least i
got one left
and that's your thank you poop
uh tila says show the box
these are the temptations tasty human
yeah chicken liver and beef flavors
i mean i didn't even notice like that
the cat is like with the cauldron with
like an arm and a leg sticking out
good on you temptations i love it i love
that they went there
with the cat eating the human thing but
like yeah it's super funny i love too
that it says on the back that there's
not actually any humans in it like don't
be alarmed and then um the other one
elsa sent us these
from chewie
uh this other one's creepy catnip
yeah so look in that cat it's just like
floating that's really weird what
so scary and for a second wait it almost
looks like that mouse is going to stick
a pickle up his butt is that what is
that what's happening hold on a second
i think that might be what's happening
[Laughter]
what do you guys think
does that look like he's going to stick
a pickle up his butt and that's why he's
like being like oh no you don't [ __ ]
mouse yeah that's funny that's funny
tina like that tina likes [ __ ] uh got
stuff now
and voltaire
i always like voltaire he's super cute
like i like and all of his songs are
like funny as [ __ ] he's actually like a
really good singer and he's like a
really good uh lyricist it's kind of
like the gothic morrissey
no he's not mopey like morrissey he's
funny but it's but not culture
he was kind of self-effacing for a while
i mean i heard a lot of this movie new
stuff but
i thought he was pretty cool
i mean everybody who doesn't love who
doesn't love when you're evil yeah our
brains that's true that was on the groom
adventures
hey this is ridiculous one of my
favorite songs of his is called god
thinks yeah god thinks what god thinks
people tell other people what god thinks
yeah that's a funny ass song yeah um i
can't remember what album it's on i have
a couple of his i have the devil's bris
and i have um
boohoo i think and a couple of other
ones i need to see [ __ ] taylor's goth
face man
face you need to go get you a gothic
outfit she's like well how do black
people be goth and i said well just she
looked up goths of color and [ __ ]
googled that [ __ ] yeah there's a bunch
of different [ __ ] looks that black
people do
and uh no it all looks good
at all it's good just depends on
whatever style i kind of feel like if
it's done right goth looks good on
everybody yeah even old people yeah
maybe that's why there's so many old
[ __ ] got always kind of had an
ethnic quality to it too
like uh you know originally it was white
people so it kind of had a european
flair to it from like hammer horror and
[ __ ] european gothic styles and stuff
but you know when you when you look at
stuff that chap the japanese are doing
they're doing like a japanese version of
with kimonos and the japanese makeup and
almost kind of like
any any
any um ethnic culture can manifest
itself in its gothic form
well that's like i said that's the nice
thing about it is that i kind of feel
like people that are sort of outside of
it don't understand like how
diverse it is how many like different
pathways you can approach it with
because every culture
has
creepy [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean or
can be and can or can be turned into
that or can be turned into creepy [ __ ]
and that's really all you have to do
there's no rules exactly as long as it's
just kind of like creepy [ __ ] well
there are some rules it has to it if
you're gonna go the ethnic route it must
conform to the ethnic motif like for
instance
um
mexican gothic is dia de los muertos
that's mexican gothic and they got
mexican goth girls that do that
jenny did that did the whole face make
it totally culturally appropriate
um
loretta vaps on instagram for me that's
the best best mexican goth girl
she even does mexican gothic cholo girls
i could see that there's not i mean it
does that [ __ ] like like a gangster girl
yeah
there's a slight overlap there honestly
yeah because they were doing the eyebrow
type things they were getting that [ __ ]
they got that [ __ ] from melania and
vampire a little bit
and or then she'll say [ __ ] it she's
going to do
mexican gothic
uh vaquero or cowboy or or or bandito
with [ __ ] sombreros and pistols and
pistols
yeah
that would also totally work did that
yeah with like the spanish
the spanish kind of mexican cowboy
outfit almost like a bullfighter type
outfit with all the seat with all the
embroidery and stuff it looked really
cool the little pedal pushers and
[ __ ] little shoes with guns and a
[ __ ] sombrero
or she'll go and just do a damn vampire
motif it's just whatever
you know like i said that's the nice
thing about goth is that you can pretty
you can goth out pretty much anything
yeah if you know what you're doing yeah
and you know like black girls will do
kind of like the traditional just like
industrial look or
kind of a generic [ __ ] goth look or
or then they'll just go to the voodoo
route
you know that looks good they're like a
core or something or
or something yeah that always looks like
yeah just a bunch of different [ __ ] that
they could do
just depends on how you're going to do
it just like the japanese girls are go
[ __ ] samurai
where it's like a gothic samurai
or a
japanese ghost kind of look you know
it looks good
yeah
that's
yeah that's what i mean like like i said
any culture because every culture has
dark myths right um you know and things
that you can like base it around and
like i said even stuff that on the
surface doesn't seem like it could be
like a bull fighter or something like
that all uni i mean goth is all about
darkness but it's also all about drama
and beauty yeah
we like is everything's really like
elaborate it has to be beautiful and
dark
and it has to
have
it has to evoke an emotion
you look at it you go oh yeah yeah yeah
and it has to have the air of
authenticity
it can't be cheap and fake it's got to
be the real thing
and some or elevated in certain ways you
can take the real thing kind of elevated
in a song
it's just an expression because i do
kind of feel like there's a whole thing
and you know i know there's a whole
thing where you can go to spirit
halloween or something like that and buy
like a goth girl costume yeah that's not
it which
we've seen that you can do that but
everyone's just going to roll their eyes
like uh we know where that came from
yeah yeah yeah and like i said i'm not
[ __ ] on spirit at all i love spirit
halloween that's like you know that's
like [ __ ] yeah candy store to me but
and uh tnot is a [ __ ] um uh nicki
minaj fan i actually
i first when i first saw nikki nicki
minaj i liked her
her visual appeal was really good not
only did she look good she was dressed
right
that was kind of like some of the stuff
that she did with the colors was kind of
like almost
a gothic industrial manifestation
of a rap star
she had a certain quality to her
a certain kind of authenticity to her
and she also kind of played with fetish
elements in her videos and stuff so i
liked her style she was
she seemed like she was in charge of
that look and was kind of i knew what
she was doing i don't think that was
corporate handlers behind that to try to
get that look i think she did know what
she was doing
tila says egyptian dress seems gothic to
me as well yeah yeah there's a lot of uh
cause i've [ __ ] i've done cleopatra a
couple of times
um i've done ancient greek as well i've
done medusa yeah that kind of stuff but
if you're gonna do a gothic
interpretation of egyptian
it has to be kind of dark and vampiric
yeah
so you're going to akasha but you know
what the amount how they showed akasha
in the movies i think they could have
done a lot better
um yeah yeah i would look and see what
other people have done
for that
and i bet you you could get you could
almost go kind of like a bastet
you know remember how the woman type
she was the cat goddess you could do you
could have something like that
um because bastet was black
and a dark-skinned girl could probably
really play that off that would look
badass
yeah if it was done right it looked
really good
just in the same way um
you had uh
[ __ ] uh black panther you know i mean
[ __ ] the black panther outfit looked
good on a [ __ ] black dude you know
you're just like yeah that that's it
yeah it would look a little weird with a
white dude wearing it yeah it looks good
i'm just gonna say i'm not saying you
can't i understand it would look weird
my boy
my boy toby dresses up in a black
panther outfit sometimes we're at the
club or that he shows up this black
panther oh yeah that's right
yeah
look at i don't know if you guys i don't
know maybe if you could not a recent or
if you're not a long time listener toby
is like a good buddy of mine from a
[ __ ] club he's one of one of my
[ __ ] best club friends and he's a
leather daddy
and he loved he [ __ ] he's way into
[ __ ] black dudes and one of his
[ __ ] outfits is so i could
[ __ ] black panther he dresses up like
that i don't
he hasn't scored in a while though
that's the thing
i said i said [ __ ] toby you got to
get on hrt he wants to get on hrt with
me he wants me to be his physical
trainer
but he's a nurse and he's constantly
[ __ ] busy they're working those dudes
to death right now
get that dude on hrt [ __ ] buff him
back up take me about six months
get him looking good and [ __ ] he just
needs a he needs a [ __ ]
buffed out [ __ ] gay black dude that's
what he needs as a
he's a size queen he's a [ __ ] power
bottom
i mean we've seen him dance and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know i'm not [ __ ] not
wearing them [ __ ] skin tight [ __ ]
pleather [ __ ] pants
that dude's [ __ ] like he's got a down
40 ounce in his [ __ ] pants those
girls are sucking sitting there looking
at his dick their [ __ ] jaws dropping
open and i said [ __ ] toby i said tell
me look at this [ __ ] power you have
over that he's [ __ ] grabbing his
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] funny
i don't know what it is about that when
he gets drunk he starts going straight
and that inner straight man and him goes
he starts jumping on [ __ ]
on jenny and start starts
he starts loving on jane
jenny course you know he's a friend of
ours so she's
all right she's like yeah
he's a good dude you know what i mean i
let him get away with it if he was
straight he wouldn't get away with it
but uh he gets straight when he gets
drunk that's [ __ ] some funny [ __ ] man
i said what are you doing because it's
just hormones
well it's just kind of like the opposite
of people that like get drunk and maybe
getting care yeah i guess
he tries to go like i said everyone's
sexuality very fluid all it takes is
alcohol and then you'd be like yes
i'm gonna try out some new [ __ ] yeah uh
lance comes in and says hi tom and jenny
hi what's up uh asked if anyone has seen
halloween kills yes we did yes so i
liked it i actually quite liked it yeah
um one of the one of the better ones
since the original i liked it better
than the 2018 one that might be a
minority opinion i'm not actually sure
but uh it was better it was better than
that one yeah i mean it's i i
actually didn't realize that anthony
michael hall was in it and he was kind
of what the main role and i love that
dude did a good job he's like awesome
everybody did a good job
it was a fun movie
um
it had really good music carpenter did
the [ __ ] theme again
the opening sequence with the [ __ ]
burning pumpkins it looked badass
uh it did deliver it delivered
um i'm not [ __ ] on it right now i still
like [ __ ] halloween three season of
the witch that's just that's my favorite
movie i kind of feel like nowadays
everybody likes it well when it came out
nobody appreciated it because they're
like what there's no michael myers
that's [ __ ] but you know i had never
seen a michael myers movie the first
halloween movie i saw was three
on on [ __ ] hbo or cinemax i don't
know which one and so i didn't have any
preconceived notions but i [ __ ] love
that silver shamrock theme and
and just what happened with the damn
androids and the [ __ ] people putting
these masks on these kids and turning
their [ __ ] heads into [ __ ] potato
bugs and [ __ ] snakes and crickets and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] me up with the stonehenge and
[ __ ]
this is what they're gonna make another
one of these halloween movies
okay
and jenny [ __ ] came up with this idea
says what if they bring in the silver
shamrock thing because they showed the
masks
in this last halloween movie they showed
those silver shamrock masks
and like i said
because halloween 2018 was just called
halloween like the first one from the
70s
and then the second one which would be
this one in the current parlance
uh had the same thing going on as
halloween two back in the old days where
lori strode's in the hospital most of
the time
so i said that can't have been an
accident yeah i think they were
deliberately
setting up a trilogy like the first one
so they're gonna have to like
so i'm kind of hoping that they do like
a weird like michael myers
silver shamrock
crossover they would be stupid not to i
mean okay but that's like a that's going
to be like a hard needle to thread
though because i kind of feel like oh i
can make a magical [ __ ] well no i know
but i'm just saying that that could
easily
be really really awesome or really
really stupid so you really kind of have
to like you have to have both of it
going on at the same time
that whatever energy that causes michael
myers not to die from all this [ __ ] that
they do
is the same energy
behind what makes those masks and this
[ __ ] sorcerer that's made because now
ai and androids are actually plausible
with the today's technology so you could
have that in there a whole company run
by damn
robots and androids
and they got something having to do with
stonehenge and [ __ ] the dark side of
the force i don't know they'll come
they'll pull some [ __ ] out of their ass
and something about
michael myers and he's tapping in the
same he's tapped into the same evil
force that this dude is and you got the
silver shamrock angle and michael myers
running simultaneous in the damn movie
it'd be a bloodbath you just got to do
it right
yeah like i said and that's they're
really going to have to like bring in
somebody that's very very up on
halloween lore yeah
to kind of
do that right because like i said
because it would be three
yeah when i thought of it when i thought
of the idea i said this could either be
the awesomest thing ever the dumbest
thing ever
um and you're gonna have to be really
really careful you got the budget
you got the budget you got the crew and
you got the writing
you could tweak that [ __ ] out and make
it just this fabulous as [ __ ]
over the [ __ ] top just bad ass horror
movie that has michael myers and the
silver shamrock angle happening in the
same story
bonus points if whoever writes slash
directs it
uh
retroactively ties the original
halloween three in with the original
franchise yeah i don't know if that
could i'm sure it could be done somehow
yeah but
i'm curious to see i don't i'm glad i
wasn't given that job because i don't
think i could think of anything but you
know
we'll see how it goes mr robot says so
i'm a hrt advisor i'm an advocate of
[ __ ] hrt for anyone who's any man
over the age of at least 35. knowing
what i've known now to went on at 40.
instead i went on and [ __ ] in my
early 50s i should have went on at 40.
oh i maintained okay up until about 50
and then i [ __ ] man that adrenopause
started hitting me but no i'm a any man
i'm a [ __ ] great advocate of it if
you're in good health
and you're over 40 you need to be on hrt
quality of your life
your energy
mental positivity your physicality it
all [ __ ] just it works out great it
works and there's other [ __ ] you know
you know me i don't really i cheat you
know what i mean i don't play fair
certain anabolics also work
alexandralone
very mild that's also good
take care of your [ __ ]
high protein low carbohydrate diet as
low as possible keep the drinking down
all right i drank you guys see it i
drink on this [ __ ] show but i'm not
drinking all the time
and working other than on the show we
don't really drink that much
and make sure you work out and do weight
training
twice a week
and i got one student he's [ __ ] of
course in the uh
he's in he's in the chat if anybody
needs any help i do a lot of [ __ ]
online
uh [ __ ]
consultations
and uh
i don't charge that much
it all depends on what you can offer
if you're a listener
you know because i'm not busy right now
i can handle more students if anybody
needs any help mr roboto asked what our
costumes were females also i'll work
with females also
and everything about females
female
biology and his female yeah
[Laughter]
well i'm a military background we call
women females i know but that's just
funny to me
um because it makes it sound like a
nature documentary um
tom was uncle fester yeah but i took
half the show you missed like the jacket
that he had on it got too hot in here
and he had the like the light bulb in
his mouth but he's just like yeah he
can't put that in there because then he
wouldn't be able to talk yeah tina said
the gypsies dress seems gothic to me and
she's nicki's kind of crazy now though
she was always crazy but you know hey
just watch how [ __ ] plays out [ __ ] we
all crazy um
she has her own style and then she goes
she said uh and she goes yeah bastet
would be amazing yeah see i haven't seen
okay the it's not a real common costume
i guess because it would kind of be a
[ __ ] to do i get it but well no i don't
think it would be you have to understand
something
when batman lore
catwoman is basically bastard yeah
okay
and you'd have earthquake somebody
mentioned that earlier that he said
eartha kit would be kind of like a good
example of of of what a african-american
female could do with a bastet
motif okay
she would be catwoman basically
but that that's good
you know that's the same as black
panther it's just the black panther
would be the male ver the male
manifestation of that but you could play
any games you wanted with that
with bastet or catwoman it would be a
mixture of egyptian and fetish you'd
want a [ __ ] badass heels
badass shoes
boots
a lot of pvc or leather
or
and you want exposed skin and i don't
know i have i've never seen utila other
than these little pictures you post in
your little icon
to do
to do bastet or catwoman right you your
physicality's got to be on point i mean
you don't have to be a 10 out of 10 but
you have to [ __ ] be good you know or
at least play to your strengths you know
i mean depending on what your build is
like
because i'm not i'm not a prejudice you
know i mean when it comes to build
uh shapes
there's a lot of different kind of
shapes that that a man appreciates you
know thin athletic voluptuous there's a
bunch of as long as it's on point
and if you're dealing with best at you'd
have to you'd have to really play to
your strengths
thank you sergeant rocco what do you say
jenny you look stunning
tom thank you thank you tom on a scale
of one to ten you're 75 000. thank you
i'll send you nibbles again soon oh [ __ ]
this one he told the hub
is this an appreciate what do you say
what do you say told the hub tom's my
hall pass oh [ __ ]
is this is this is this a man saying
this
is this i think i got a feeling that
only only men talk loud would talk that
way
you never know you know yeah well his
name is mr roboto though would it no
sergeant rocco sergeant rocco yes man
probably
does it have to be to that i don't know
i appreciate it
[Laughter]
see
my my my handles like uh online or are
gender neutral so yeah
you know
uh what i was gonna say i'm surprised i
actually i'm surprised i don't see more
people dressed up like
various egyptian gods because man
there's a whole panoply in there that
are
man you could be
there's like a lot of cool ones
right
yeah um you can have like falcon head
you could be like the big scarab deal
you could do all kind of stuff there's a
crocodile-headed one the most modern
play
on the egyptian motif that would be goth
friendly would be that movie the crusade
was in stargate remember the movie
where you had the that was some pretty
everybody remembers that yeah and that
was kind of like a high-tech almost kind
of like a gothic version of something
that the egyptians might have you know
egyptians from another planet
so
yeah you could go that way
i think you gotta remember with the
egyptian stuff you gotta look at all
those paintings they all wore wigs and
they had big hair and bags
the women did
well
yeah i'm all about big hair and bangs
love the bangs they were probably
braided it's probably braided stuff
they didn't they were all shave bald
male and female in ancient egypt they
didn't have hair
they didn't have reliable running water
and they were
afraid of lice infestations
so everyone was shaved which makes a lot
of sense i lived in egypt for six months
yeah i mean that air is not would not be
good if you didn't have running water
yeah
and you're in a
densely packed
city at that with primitive technology
so everyone was shaved so they just wore
wigs
uh
according to the drawings it's hard to
tell what the wigs were
some of the stuff that's been come off
of mummies and stuff it's basically it's
seemed to be finely braided
wigs made out of horse hair usually if
you're a rich horsetail
so they were like little plaits little
small ones
and it was
usually around jaw to shoulder length
and bangs
sometimes it was just down the middle
but it depend on the era because they
were around people don't realize that
the ancient egyptians were around for
thousands of years
they were around for a long long time
and the whole pyramid period was
uh what was called new kingdom so that
was actually
the towards the end
and then later they ended up being
part of the
part of the greco-roman empire
you know the cleopatra [ __ ] she was a
ptolemaic ruler she was actually from
from greece
um
egypt had different rulers foreign
rulers a lot of times it's just changing
hands
it was just a place where people would
go
it would go there from all over the
world
for you know a couple thousand years
so it was kind of multi-ethnic
multi-racial
and it's kind of a melting pot kind of
way america was but it was just around
for a long long time
it ended up being poor though because uh
egypt became a desert it really wasn't
always a desert
and in its early it was
you could grow you could grow food there
a lot easier [ __ ] in the old kingdom
when it when it first
formed
but i lived there it's [ __ ] cool
probably really much cooler back in the
day
to see what it was like then
might have been a pain in the ass though
because they were very religious very
religious
yeah that's awesome and according to
like
there there are trial transcripts of
people who are being sentenced to death
for [ __ ] grave robbery
and some of those people were saying
[ __ ] that like makes sense to us but it
didn't make sense to them they're like
you guys are spending all this money and
all this wealth burying these people to
these gods that don't exist while we're
out here starving
yeah it might be a little so frustrating
you know you're like we're just stealing
things from people
that are dead and that they can't access
and i'm trying to feed my family
and they take that dude out and execute
him that was with the court that's the
court proceedings were saying nobody
believes in this and you're making us do
it
so that's what the kind of [ __ ] they
were saying so
totalitarian and it was a religious uh
theocracy it was totalitarian
it's funny the middle east and religion
goes way back
tila says the women wore cones of solid
perfume on top of their heads yeah they
said [ __ ] on fire it would melt and go
ahead and melt
the molecule down to the sun to sent
them throughout the day that's actually
a good idea if you think about it
they did a lot of weird [ __ ] though that
wasn't really a good idea like putting
camel dong up in your coochie to [ __ ]
help you with [ __ ] fight [ __ ]
pregnancy and weird [ __ ] like that it
didn't yeah i heard about that he did
all kinds of weird [ __ ]
it probably worked though maybe because
nobody wanted to stick their dick in you
yeah
when
so you're not going to get pregnant
uh you know this is probably like the
thing but yeah i'm just i'm amazed that
especially after
i don't know i just kind of feel like i
don't see you see a lot of cleopatras
still like a halloween but you don't
really see a lot of the other
egyptian gods that's kind of a shame
might have to rectify that one of these
days
i don't know i kind of feel like there's
not
honestly one of the one of my
aspirational halloween costumes just
going away from asian egypt for a second
a couple years ago i was like you know
what i think that this year i want to be
kali
so i kind of researched and i was kind
of like okay well i have to paint myself
blue
and i have to figure out how i'm gonna
like put some extra arms on and without
it looking cheesy and then i have to
like make a skirt out of heads
and uh so i don't know it sounded really
fun but i was like yeah i can't afford
like to do this to any great degree
and then like a year or two after i had
decided to do that but i couldn't afford
to do it
i saw who's that model that was on
what the [ __ ] was that show project
runway or whatever the [ __ ] heidi klum
she dressed up as kali one year and it
was
amazing it looked really good well
because she's like [ __ ] rich right so
obviously she can just like do a badass
costume and i'm like well [ __ ] i can't
do it now
because
when i thought of it i'd never seen
anybody dress like that
but that's one of those costumes that if
you're gonna do it you can't like cheap
out on the [ __ ] you have to like go
whole hog because i was like look you
have to paint your whole body blue you
have to do this whole [ __ ] thing you
have to have like i was like can i do
mannequin arms it's like i don't really
want to do arms like pantyhose like
stuffed with like cotton because that
looks super cheesy thank you again
sergeant rocco three purple hearts and a
bronze star tom hub has two purple
hearts and a silver star paris island
they didn't teach me to duck he's army
just stupid
okay i'm gonna tell him that when he
gets back
but uh but yeah so i never to do that
because like i said i could never afford
it and then heidi klum just did it
better anyway and i was just kind of
like okay well i guess i can't do that
but
after that my aspirational halloween
costume became and i think i've
mentioned this before
um
the chick from dagon like the
so so i'd need to make like this gold
crown situation she needed to have she'd
need to be in a wheelchair
she would need to have tentacles
and she has this gold kind of outfit but
it's like it you know i just thought
it'd be really cool but
um i don't know like i said that i was
like that'd be like a really badass
costume but then tom's like well nobody
know who that is but i was like i don't
know that doesn't matter to me like i
said we for a long time we thought about
doing
uh clytus and general kala from flash
gordon but again i kind of feel like
that would cost a lot of money to do
when i just haven't been able to afford
it
you know
sergeant rocco sent another super chat
and said three purple hearts and a
bronze star tom okay cool hub has two
purple hearts and a silver star paris
island
they didn't teach me to duck
he's army just stupid lol
[Laughter]
all right talk for a second because i
gotta go to the bathroom yeah tell me
more about that what battles are we
talking about here what years are we
talking about
um
now t
i know you like
i know you like that rap music i was
just bad i wanted to tell you about you
guys can [ __ ] check this out too
everybody else listening
back in the 90s they had an experimental
rap bad
that i [ __ ]
stumbled into by accident i walked into
a record store
when i was coming out of
i think i was coming out of basic
training and i [ __ ] went to this
record store maybe it wasn't basic
training i don't remember the exact year
i just went into this record store and
they were playing in this record store
this [ __ ] badass [ __ ] music and it
was one song after another and i was
sitting there listening to it
and it was an experimental back rap band
that didn't go anywhere it was called
new kingdom
and it was
rap
but it was kind of like a southwest
version of it
it was
a mixture of blues
rap
psychedelic
and
i don't know
you just have to
i'm gonna try to see what the name of
that [ __ ] album was
if i can find it
then the main track was called paradise
don't come cheap but i don't think
that's the name of the album it's called
i'm thinking of this because we were
talking about
egypt
yeah okay that is the name of it
of the album it's called paradise don't
come cheap
oh now i can see everybody
that's what the album looks like
try that [ __ ] out
that was like one of the best albums
i've ever heard and it never went
anywhere
i think they only did a couple of albums
maybe one or two
and he just disappeared it's like
something
it's like something out of the desert
and he talks about jimi hendrix when he
was a kid
he was
sitting there looking at a poster with
[ __ ] jimi hendrix on a horse with a
holster and all kind of just
and then he was tripping out and [ __ ]
they talking about going into outer
space because of the [ __ ] drugs that
he was on
it's psychedelic rap and blues and with
a southwest
[ __ ] style too it's really really
good
he's ahead of his time that was in the
90s see what see what year that was
i think it might have been 91.
you got a dog jenny good okay thank you
yeah uh john goris says haven't dressed
up in years i just do low effort like a
bomb
[Laughter]
i know it's like a good last but i don't
know i'm just
man i it's like i'm just so into like
halloween and i'm so into like spooky
[ __ ] that
i can't just
if i'm gonna do it i have to like do a a
good like do a really big
deal kind of thing you know what i mean
the album was from 1996 so no i was out
of the army when i found that then i
don't remember where it was when i found
it but yeah
check that out you will like it
another thing i was looking up recently
too is that uh strangely
like it's not so strangely one of the
top costumes
this year
although
it didn't come out
you know long enough before halloween
for there to be costumes for it was
squid game
everybody's dressing up like squid game
this year
and there's like a way i read this
article about how everybody wants to
dress their babies up like in squid game
i'm like that's a little weird but okay
considering like how kind of [ __ ] up
that show is
but
hey
you know
i saw i was looking like earlier i was
looking at like best halloween costumes
or whatever
somebody had taken their they had two
little little kids like babies or
toddlers
and i guess this was a couple years back
when it came out you know the stephen
king thing
and some they had built
um like a little portable
uh like a sewer grate and one of the
babies they dress up like pennywise and
they put them down in the sewer grate
and then the other baby they dress up
like georgie like in the little yellow
slicker
and
then like so the little baby that was
dressed like the
that was dressed in the yellow raincoat
was up here and then they had like the
pennywise baby like looking like hey i'm
gonna eat your arm off it's like oh my
god i was like that's so [ __ ] awesome
i love when people dress up because you
know with their babies they don't know
any better you know what i mean yeah you
can put you can make them wear whatever
ridiculous [ __ ] you want so
and honestly one of my favorite costumes
of all time was these pm this was like a
few years back but i remember somebody
taking a picture of it it was a kid they
were like a little little kid they were
probably like five or six
and they dressed him like edward
scissorhands
and
they went whole hog man so the kid had
like
the outfit that he had on looked exactly
like johnny depp's outfit for like with
all the buckles and everything like that
except really really small because he
was like a little kid and he had like
all they did all his hair like all
robert smithed out and he had like the
little hands and stuff and it looked so
[ __ ] good i mean that kid looked
awesome restarted rocco's comment where
is that it's up there somewhere
uh tom shot in the leg in panama stabbed
in kuwait city outside fallujah stood in
front of a
corpsman who was working on a buddy
knowing the car nearby was rigged to
explode lost 17 inches of intestines i
gotta tell you a story
if you were in panama i gotta tell you a
story about a panama vet
his name was lutz
[ __ ] pfc lutz
i show up to uh first in the 506
camp grieves right outside the dmz
in korea
it's just right out of basic training
man i'm getting ready to [ __ ]
train up to go on the freaking first dmz
mission
uh now we were going to go into [ __ ]
guard post phase
we had this dude who showed up
around the same time like about a week
before my whole cohort showed up there
and his name was lutz
and he just can't we just thought this
[ __ ] was just this nutty
pathological liar you look at him and
he's just this kind of dweeby skinny
dude and he goes yeah
i just got back
from panama my unit in panama i'm gonna
get a purple heart and bronze star or a
silver star and all this other [ __ ]
and he goes deer in panama
looking um a truck ran through my uh the
truck ran through my um oh
what do you call it
[ __ ]
roadblock and i jumped on the front of
the truck
and was shooting at the guy driving
and [ __ ] he ran over me but i went
underneath the truck and grabbed the
bottom of the truck and came around the
side and [ __ ] stuck the [ __ ]
barrel of the [ __ ] a2 up through the
door and shot him and killed him and
when the truck
crashed i then heard
machine gun fire coming from over the
top of this hill
so i ran up there on my own and [ __ ]
engaged this machine the bell fed
machine gun i killed that guy took that
machine took his machine gun and shot
back at some of these other pdf dudes i
killed four more of them
and [ __ ] you know then i went back
and [ __ ] you know my guys you know my
friends at the roadblock they were all
wounded and [ __ ] i helped evacuate
them so anyway we started making fun of
this dude
instead of operation just cause we
called it operation just luts
lutz did all this [ __ ] he did everything
in the whole [ __ ] world so we were
making fun of it
so i was still new at that time i'd been
there for about three or four weeks
hearing this we're still going almost
still just like just doing them process
and getting ready to [ __ ] train up
for the next phase we had a company
formation
and and first sergeant comes out and
[ __ ] calls pfc lutz
front and center
and we're all going oh he's in big
trouble
for all that [ __ ] that he's been [ __ ]
talking all right
first sergeant goes
he goes and he starts gets these papers
pulls without he goes pfc lutz i do
hereby [ __ ] promote you to special
spec for i'm like what
i award you with [ __ ] this is the bra
star
for fowler and [ __ ] panama for
[ __ ] stopping a truck and engaging a
machine gun post and killing three enemy
soldiers this and that but and then
we're like well whoa what the [ __ ] it
was all true it's all true and he goes
and i'm [ __ ] ordering you to go to
pldc send you out here and say we're
gonna [ __ ] make him an nco and they
shipped him out
for like three days you're like dude we
were high-fiving and we thought you were
[ __ ] he was oh no no it wasn't we
thought we he we thought he was
bullshitting us did you feel bad
i was so so i was still so new
that i was just [ __ ] like wow you
know what i mean i didn't know what to
think i thought he was [ __ ]
and like four days later he was gone
they just [ __ ]
vanished
because they sent him the news to school
the pldc school and [ __ ] they were
gonna make him an e5
and i guess they just sent him somewhere
else
but we operation just luts
yeah it was true
it was true
and he said wait we were like so why
haven't they awarded you all this well
see that i had to get out of there and
they [ __ ] up the paperwork my
my first sergeant got [ __ ]
transferred and this it's gonna catch up
you know
it was it was a [ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] up he should have been
awarded that [ __ ]
like a couple months before see that
just goes to show
because this is 91. everybody has a
crazy story like that yeah yeah most
people are operations just luts i don't
know you know i know your your man was
in [ __ ] panama maybe he heard about
that engagement now i had another friend
who ended up being my [ __ ] um his
name was [ __ ] sergeant smith
and sergeant smith ended up in the site
he was in that same mission he ended up
being in the cyclopedia
botanica as the photograph of the dude
standing there when he said operation
just caused the [ __ ] invasion of
panama for some reason they just had his
his photograph
he was just that's what the media picked
up on and he had some badass pictures
of where they [ __ ] attacked this pdf
compound and they [ __ ] shot a guard
post out in front of a pdf compound with
an at4 rocket
then it went through the [ __ ] they
shot at the door just as a dude walked
out just as the guard [ __ ] walked
into the doorway that at4 hit him
right in the mid right in the gut
and then they initiated the whole attack
they were shooting up the [ __ ]
parking lot [ __ ] pdf was coming out
on motorcycles they shot some of those
dudes because they were just in a duty
day they didn't know they were in war it
was a [ __ ] sneak attack on the
panamanian defense force
and then afterwards they had cameras and
[ __ ] and when they took a picture of
that dude who was in the [ __ ] guard
in the guard post and it was it looked
like a man coming up out of the ground
it was just a dude sitting there with
his arms like this and it was just just
from here up with his hand like that
with his arms out he looked alive he was
dead blown in half
by an at4 it was weird
sergeant rocco then says i had served in
the israeli defense force oh you're an
idea before i went into the marines yeah
um i'd been wounded in the idf but they
don't give medals they bust you a rank
and call you stupid
well i told i i just told a story a
couple days back when i was hanging out
with the idf of the idf up in the a lot
they were good dudes and they i think
they were if i remember correctly they
were [ __ ] stationed up in jericho
that was when i was on the uh mfo
mission in egypt
all right i was impressed with the idf
you know the deal
thank you very much trey
uh that's for the mary shelley
frankenstein show i loved it one of your
best episodes ever i know it was but i
was waiting to do that show for such a
long time and i'm gonna do gothic the
movie like later on this week too
sergeant rocco then says tom jenny next
time i get to florida please allow me
the privilege of buying you drinks
you may grant that would be awesome
actually
we should hang out yeah uh they were
talking about like uh little kid
halloween costumes i just remembered
another one that i really love and this
one's kind of [ __ ] up but i love
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
somebody
dressed their kid like their baby
up like a lobster and carried them
around in a pot
like they were
damn
and i was like that is so sick and yet i
love you guys that is so [ __ ] funny
yeah i mean that's funny like i said
it's a baby they don't know
they you know you have to clean up their
poop all day long okay it's like you can
dress them up for your own amusement if
you want to
they won't know any different well
unless you take pictures of them and
then like it haunts them the rest of
their life but you know
still i like that idea though
i was like i said so you're not really
gonna eat the baby it's a lobster
yeah trey said uh i remember you telling
me on facebook years ago you want to do
a mary shelley show yeah it's like
because i just love all the
all the [ __ ] about that and it's just
kind of like i kept putting it in the
patreon poll and i was like why didn't
you win god damn it
i'm just i want to do it i even did that
whole [ __ ] board game and everything
you know what i mean
uh sergeant rocco then says in the
soviet union we didn't do halloween so
when i got here it was amazing to dress
up and have so much fun i love halloween
see i'm see
honestly i i feel bad for countries that
don't
celebrate halloween as much i know it's
kind of more of a global phenomenon
right nowadays yes yeah and uh honestly
everybody should i'm i'm a halloween
evangelist yeah that's what i'm saying
well look halloween's for everybody well
look at look at what you did i mean
[ __ ] mexican halloween is spreading
you know i mean that mexicans halloween
look is spreading too yeah it's just
it's global now
like i said in a lot of ways
i mean christmas is awesome too but
halloween is kind of like
it's the best holiday clearly yeah
i mean
american christmas though is the best
still
i think yeah and it's guys just
something european and like laplandish
like i like christmas too i'm not
[ __ ] yeah christmas is good too
uh america's got the christmas right but
we got
we got halloween right too but i'd have
to give it to the mexicans the the
mexicans got halloween the visuals right
from dia de los muertos that looked good
too especially for outfits
yeah that looks really good
i'm trying to think of who else has a
good halloween and i don't know it's not
really coming to mind
america and mexico leaders when it comes
to that
yeah we kind of kick ass in the
halloween department like i said we take
that [ __ ] serious yeah
but like i said i like christmas too
honestly like honestly once it gets to
be autumn i'm just so happy that the
summer's over and then there's all then
you get like piled up with all these
holidays like around the same time
period and like i said we have halloween
which is the best holiday and then you
have thanksgiving uh which is also an
awesome holiday because it's just a
holiday about food
and you're just like supposed to just
stuff yourself and sleep which
that's i'm totally on board with that
um and like i said christmas
you can do dark christmas too because
i'm really into like the whole christmas
ghost story and krampus kind of
situation i'm into all that kind of [ __ ]
too so you know there's that whole thing
too do y'all decorate and put up a tree
for christmas yeah yes uh she might be
asking tammy okay um but yeah we do
we usually we put a tree up we got a
little a big tall tree last year because
we had like a tall
ceiling yeah which i guess it'll work in
this place too oh where are we gonna put
it
you can i mean the thing about this
house is that none of the windows
are really visible from the street yeah
because the one window that's like in
the front room
it's kind of covered by bushes you put
it right in the front room though when
you walk in you see it probably
is
jenny
i i'm a cultural christian all right i
was
raised as a christian earlier on early
on in a christian military academy i
took this [ __ ] serious for a long time
but the more
you find out about christianity and
religions and mythology in general you
see that it's a roman religion right and
it's a lot of mythology in it but i
really like the christian motif and
even though
christmas is not very christian it's
christian adjacent you know it's more
pre-christian
but i like all that [ __ ] i like all that
[ __ ] i [ __ ] do i believe it
no
uh do i believe some of the messages
yeah yeah you know all religions have
at least all of them at least mostly
have good messages you know
um
even if you look at anton levay's
[ __ ] interpretation of satanism still
had good messages in it it's just
it's just a thing their styles their
styles and they're just philosophies and
messages
if they make you feel good and get you
through rough times that's what you do
yeah like i said there's no reason why
you can't like i said my [ __ ] atheist
ass i love christmas i've always loved
christmas since i was kids like i don't
need all that jesusy [ __ ] it doesn't you
know that doesn't it doesn't mean
anything to me because i didn't grow up
like that so it's like man i just like
the trees and the lights and it's like
oh good will toward men well that's nice
everybody could use that i don't even
mind the jesusy stuff
just
just don't take it that seriously you
know you don't pose it on other people
you don't kill other people over these
things you know what i mean this is just
culture
now if somebody sent me like a jesusy
christmas card i'd but i'm not gonna
like do anything bad but i i'd probably
like roll my eyes
sure it depends on what it is
like i said if i'm gonna do
if i'm gonna do christmas
i like doing kind of like
i like doing like dark kind of christmas
what i don't like is i don't like any
kind of uh religious zealotry
see that's the problem is when you have
religious religious people who are
zealots who are trying to impose their
version of reality on you
yeah i mean but if somebody sends you a
[ __ ] badass catholic jesus doing like
this with rays and [ __ ] no i love that
yeah i mean like i said as long as
you're not being a dick about it i'm not
really right because i i like
i like a lot of that um iconography yeah
it looks great
it's just that the catholics got jesus
down all right
south american central american
catholics they know how to draw that
[ __ ] okay that's it
and that's what it means but it doesn't
have to have any rational message behind
it it's emotion
that's you know the story and there it
is and just yeah
now you don't take that thing go around
try to worry about converting people or
[ __ ] making people don't play video
games because he wouldn't like it you
know
that's not what that [ __ ] yeah that's
not about
you know that's not what those messages
are about
like i said as long as you're if you're
into that that's cool but as long as
you're i mean as long as you just kind
of like keep it to yourself and other
people are doing their own [ __ ] it's
like well we do this for christmas
everybody's like everything's cool it's
cool as long as you're not like hurting
anybody else
you're not you know it's funny just do
what you want to do man
i'm i'm not going to get all up in
anyone's business about how they
celebrate various holidays it's yeah
like i said that's that's not my house
they're the you know
it's not me what do i care i was never
really emo some people i think they act
like they are emotionally damaged by
that [ __ ] just because you got some
[ __ ] to try to force i've never
really had that experience
[ __ ] i see pictures of [ __ ] mary
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] jesus and
manger scenes and [ __ ] to me it's it's
just it's just as cool as seeing
anubis or [ __ ] you know what i mean
or anubis or [ __ ] bastard or egyptian
stuff or ancient roman stuff you know
dionysus jupiter
it's it's all that same universe
you know it's it's mythology well like i
said it depends on what it is because i
have personally bought
let's for example uh postcards of like
religious art
from you know the met in new york or
something like that just because i liked
that particular painting i usually like
like el greco and stuff like that
because his shit's like weird looking
but
um so i'm not averse to religious
imagery in general like i said i don't
it's just that sometimes i kind of feel
like
you you guys all have that one family
member yeah that sends you the christmas
cards
uh you know with the jesus he [ __ ] on it
and then like there'll be some kind of
passive aggressive yeah kind of message
in there that's what i'm trying and like
i said i'm not gonna i'm not offended
i'm just kind of like okay yeah yeah you
haven't been going to church lately
whatever i'm so happy yeah i don't have
any of those in my family i don't really
either honestly
i mean i like if i'm gonna send
christmas cards which i haven't for a
while i used to
but
i just i like the ones that are just
kind of like just seasonal i especially
like ones with like little snowmans on
them i like little snowmans yeah i like
little little cute snowman so for a long
time i had once with like a little bit
like a little miniature snowman and it's
like that card was so [ __ ] cute that
like every time i looked at it i was
just kind of like
and i had like a [ __ ] ton of them so i
used up like a couple of years in a row
but i wish i could find those again i
really like those
uh alex rivera says you gotta watch kirk
cameron's movie saving christmas oh [ __ ]
okay so
i've seen parts of it i watched the
god-awful movies breakdown of it like
the podcast if you guys don't know
god-awful movies um if you're religious
it's it'll probably be really offensive
so like don't watch it but they're a
bunch of atheists and they watch
christian movies and they do like these
really long
really really offensive like breakdowns
of them and they're super super funny
but they did when i'm saving christmas
and it sounded
hilarious so i might actually i don't
know do i want to watch it
i don't know if i want to watch it or if
i just want to watch somebody making fun
of it i can i don't know it's it's
conundrum
[Laughter]
you know
starting rock is also talking about
hanukkah and the soviet union
so i guess he's he's russian jewish and
from the idf and the [ __ ] so i don't
know how old you are but you've been
everywhere bro
yeah
then says this is going to come out
weird but
my mom and one of her brothers survived
auschwitz
10 brother sisters killed by nazis one
by stalin who's saying this sergeant
rocco okay yeah mom raises religious
just to keep us yiddish speaking
well there you go
um tell you what the
israel had decent food i mean i don't
know if you know if you've been there it
had good food
the middle east had good food just as
long as you were in the right place it
all did
ma uh the
when i was in israel they had this uh
baba ganoush that was [ __ ] fantastic
it was like this roasted eggplant
it was all spiced it was whole pieces of
it wasn't
pureed
big old pieces of like eggplant they had
garlic and spices i think it was cumin
and everything we were eating it on
bread manish it was so good
but
[ __ ] that actually sounds good right now
yeah we don't have any eggplants sitting
there it's just we were eating thomas
made really you've made baba ghana yeah
i've made it before
normally i blend it though yeah bigger
puree this was like whole pieces of
onion
and an eggplant
and it was in oil i think with garlic
and cumin
and it had been roasted it was it was
roasted first before it was all put
together
and we were taking like flat pieces of
bread kind of like naan bread or pita
and we were just scooping that [ __ ] up
to big hunks of it
and we were just eating it
i remember where they were where we were
when we were eating that
i remember that
we were [ __ ] starving
and what was funny is that if you were
an american soldier in israel and you're
speaking english everybody around you is
[ __ ] looking at you and they start
sending you free [ __ ]
when you're in korea koreans don't
[ __ ] really like show at that time
that i was there didn't show much
gratitude for your service to help
defend their country
but israel did
in the time that i was there in the 90s
you couldn't go anywhere without having
[ __ ] drinks come your way
any of those clubs or restaurants or
although you got to pay the bill and the
[ __ ] it never shows up because
somebody paid it
i would say i put israel at the top in
terms of
just like and there would be like five
of us in there
some of them would speak english and
they'd come up and talk to us but most
of them most of them did speak english
but most of them got kind of stayed
you know wouldn't confront you they
would just
buy something for you
this whole thing about you know like
jews being cheap not in israel
no
it's hard to pay for something there
now i think i don't know what had
happened in [ __ ] um
in the uh
i think that was around the time where
we cut some kind of deal for it with the
f-15 eagles
we had sold them a bunch i think f-15s
and
and and did a bunch of other stuff there
was a bunch of military aid that just
happened
and uh when we would go down there
we would go down there [ __ ] for like
r r we just couldn't buy anything they
wouldn't take our money
it was amazing that's nice yeah
uh john gorra says i don't need god to
be passive aggressive
[Laughter]
right i don't either uh yeah so and then
alex rivera says kirk cameron would send
that type of card that's exactly the
type of person
that would send that type of card
um and then trey says oh tracy in this
movie oh man that kirk cameron movie is
just ugg so bad it's funny like i said
i've seen clips of it
um
on some channels that i watched that
make fun of those kind of movies
and i almost want to watch it but i
don't know if i want like that rattling
around my brain for the rest of my life
i don't know it's
half a one i don't know and then yeah
and alex says i don't know it's pretty
rough to sit through that's kind of the
impression that i got it looks
insufferable as like a lot of those
movies do
and then um
alex rivera wait what was the name of
the channel jenny just mentioned where
atheists watch christian movies it's a
podcast and it's called
god-awful movies yeah it's good it's fun
it's usually three guys
um
and they it's not always the same ones
because sometimes one of them can't come
or whatever but
they've done they do one a week i think
um i haven't heard them for a while but
i think they're still around and they
always do i think they have a pure flix
subscription which is christian netflix
if you didn't know
um and there's also oh there's another
guy too that's on uh youtube what's his
name
i think i mentioned it before his name's
nick something nick and then he has like
an italian last name but he's kind of
like this really really um like over the
top like gay guy but he does he doesn't
just do like christian movies but he has
a subset because he usually just does
like cheesy disney movies and [ __ ] like
that and does like breakdowns of them
and they're super super funny he's
hilarious and uh but he does some
christian movies too and it's like
really really funny but yeah god awful
movies is like really really funny but
like i said if you're any if you're in
any way religious you might find it very
very offensive
but it's funny though it's very funny oh
my god
what makes it they're so [ __ ] funny
what makes it funny okay even if you
were religious it would be funny
it's because
the christian film
movie making industry is [ __ ] bad all
right most of that [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
cheesy and they're talking about the
other kirk cameron movie they said with
the one where he was a firefighter with
the porn addiction yeah that's fireproof
uh so i've seen they did it they did a
an episode on that as well so yeah i
even knew that one
there are good christian movies there
are good jewish movies like [ __ ]
darren aronowski's [ __ ] noah which is
christian and jewish
right from the [ __ ] apocrypha
jubilees and [ __ ]
you can do that you can you can do
religion right
you can just gotta have [ __ ] good
writing
good you know what i mean
good direction money
all right and yeah you can't
worry about what the what religious
people are going to say because in
religion everything can be interpreted
one way or the other depending on
whatever [ __ ]
sect you're in you have to be hardened
to that
and really you want the material to be
right out of scripture
almost literally the more literal the
more bizarre it is okay so hence the
more fun the more fun it is like they
need to literally do the book of
revelations that [ __ ] would be with cg
that [ __ ] would be awesome yeah see i
don't know why nobody's done that yet oh
it'd be awesome that would be excellent
i would watch that i recommend noah
i recommend uh uh what was the one that
had that they were going out killing
those demons the one that was frailty
frailty that was a good one that one
[ __ ] wigged me out
um
well like i said you could argue that
the exorcist is a cat
it's a pro catholic movie you could
argue that the entire omen series is
that
but it's also a good movie yeah because
it's not necessarily trying to like push
an agenda but i think the problem with a
lot of you know this kind of like
christian entertainment right is that
one they're really hamstrung by a lot of
stuff that they can't put in the movie
um you know and let's go back to the
kirk cameron movie fireproof where he
was playing a firefighter who had a porn
addiction and it's like they
i don't even think they can say the word
porn in the movie or they obviously they
can't show any porn or they can't so
everything's like implication so it's
like you're already kind of like working
within all these limitations of [ __ ] you
can't do
because it's like well we can't put that
in the movie because people will get
offended so and the and two they also
have an agenda that they're pushing and
they're not
real subtle about
the messaging
um so everything is kind of in service
to that message
so you can't it's hard to have like a
good story or like entertaining
characters or like that when everything
is geared toward one
message that you're trying to send so
it's also everything yeah it's a you
really just can't have a naturalistic or
an organic type of story unfolding
because it's like well we have to have
everything turn out this way and we
can't do this and that the other thing
it just seems like you're you know
you're handicapping yourself is what
you're doing yeah thank you james knapp
what do you say uh have you heard of the
ammons haunting possession of a house
family in gary indiana yes i think i
wrote about that in my book actually uh
in 2012 would love to hear you do a deep
dive on it i don't you know what i don't
think we've done a show about that i'll
write it down yeah i should because
where'd my pen go
right here michael fester's light bulb
but uh yeah so i need to like i said i
wrote about that in my book i'm pretty
sure because i know that name um but i
don't think we've ever done a show on it
so uh we'll have to get around to that
one of these days i'll put that in the
poll and see what happens
uh yeah do do do do do how are you guys
tagging people in comments by the way
um we don't tag people oh well they're
asking he'd ask another okay he was
asking all right
but yeah so i just kind of feel like
i don't know man there's a whole i kind
of feel like pure flix
i don't know if he owns part of it or
something like that but there's this
dude named david r white
and he's in
a [ __ ] ton of movies that are on that
[ __ ]
i don't have pure flicks but i've
subscribed to some channels that make
fun of movies that are on there
and it's like it's really sad because
that dude is in a bunch of them and
another thing that they do too is like a
bunch of the movies that they do
you can tell that they're doing like as
cheaply as possible they'll
they'll record like a bunch of actors
you know doing their thing like in front
of a green screen
and then they buy
uh backgrounds like you know corporate
office background
like you know and then they'll just like
drop it behind the actors so it's like
they don't even have any sets or
anything
so it's like but obviously you can tell
that that's what it is so it just
everything just comes across as really
like cheap and low effort
so i think that's another thing is that
they don't um
they don't really seem to want to spend
any money on this stuff
and so everything comes across as just
looking really
crappy like as far as like special
effects go
everything all the backgrounds are green
screen even if it's just like an office
or something that you could easily rent
right now getting people agreeing with
me about that yeah there are some good
religious films that i have another one
that was good was passion of the christ
because
mel gibson just went all in on it we're
going to make so he basically made it a
horror movie we're going to make a
horror
movie that christians will respond to
and [ __ ] happens in it and they [ __ ]
love he totally suckered a bunch of
christians into going to see like a
torture porn movie that's yeah that's
really funny but that made sense that
makes sense
that makes sense from christian theology
though
you know what i mean you got a deep dive
into the suffering of jesus because he
died for you and this is all this you
know that's so now that's exactly what
they would [ __ ] he knew what he was
doing that's exactly what they would
like
you know and um that was a good movie
that was a good movie
and and [ __ ] christians liked it
and it made a lot of money so i'm gonna
say that was a good movie
uh i actually preferred noah
darren aronofsky's noah
uh frailty i think because that was like
a christian horror movie well and then
they also made last temptation of christ
i liked that one too i liked that movie
a lot but christians had a [ __ ] [ __ ]
fit well
well that was overlooked jesus didn't
have sex
stop it it wasn't just that they were
that was the main thing yeah it wasn't
just that it was a bunch of little
things i think a lot of it some of it
had to do with the fact that david bowie
was in it they didn't like that
um it was it was a good movie that was a
good movie i thought it was a great
movie actually um
trying to think of another john goris
says the exorcism of emily rose is kind
of religious yeah it is yeah it is
that's also a pretty good flick also um
the one uh [ __ ] what was the greatest
story ever told and that the one that
had moses and [ __ ] pharaoh i like a
lot of those kind of old like religious
episodes
yeah i like those that was good
um trying to think what else was good
it was religious religious motif
uh
tammy said i was going through my
uncle's stuff and found a copy of
dianetics i wish he was still alive so i
could ask him about it he wasn't
religious in any way
i kind of feel like a lot of people had
that book though back in the day it was
a huge selling because
i remember yeah i remember like back in
the 80s they had that commercial for it
it was on all the time that commercial
yeah and it didn't say that it had
anything to do with scientology
it was a religion no
it was just like a self-help book so i
think a lot of people might have bought
it and this without knowing they had
this fantastic commercial with an
animated volcano blowing up and really
good voice over and i was a little kid
not know what the [ __ ] that was i'm
listening to go oh wow that's impressive
wow
and it was like an animated volcano like
something out of them the old lord of
the rings animated movie it's like that
that evidently was a famous animator who
ended up going doing movies and [ __ ] but
no just because just because he had that
book that didn't mean he was a
scientologist
and uh the dying scientology in the
dianetics phase is very very basic
it's hard to get it was just something
designed to suck you in
to it
so just because you read that that
didn't mean that
you knew anything about scientology
yeah because i kind of feel like a lot
of people bought that without really
knowing that it was related
uh sergeant rocco says sorry dear
comrades but i have to jump off jenny
again you look stunning thank you and
tom wipes drool off lips oh stop oh you
stop
got another recommendation for these
dogs of war coming after this tender
meat oh goodness yeah
poor tom it doesn't everyone's jumping
on you on your little bald head that's
what it is i know yeah uh tammy also
recommends noah that is actually a great
movie yeah that's a great movie um
ben hur oh yeah that's another good one
yeah i forgot about that one i forgot
about that the darren aronofsky noah is
like uh it's like something out of alien
or prometheus or [ __ ] you know i mean
it's it's almost kind of like a like a
good ridley scott movie it's it's
science fiction
and and really that's what that's what
the story of genesis is
it's it's like some other science
fiction
beings from the heavens and [ __ ]
making being enchained into the earth
and [ __ ] waters of the [ __ ] ocean
and waters of the of the sky opening up
simultaneously to swallow up mankind to
destroy it because it's [ __ ] up you
know what i mean
so yeah it's like right out of science
fiction and that's how it's shown it's
pretty
close to the general story and that's
and here's the thing people say that is
not what it says in genesis this
that story was told over and over again
there's two versions of it in genesis
there's another version of it in
i think jubilees
or and then it's i think it's even
talked about in a in the apocrypha
and then the original is in the epic of
gilgamesh because that story is a copy
the epic of gilgamesh and [ __ ] is
also the flood story that's where they
got it
pre-dates everybody in the ancient world
believed in a great flood story with the
gods trying to wipe yeah that had been
going around for like four years and
nothing that is the
the ancient the ancient jews and the
christians did not have a monopoly on
that
that's pre-jewish
by uh what a large thousands years so
everybody believed that
and all other religions adopted it
because they couldn't believe that that
was true
you go up to the top of a mountain
you're gonna find seashells so of course
it was all underwater what happened well
they were bad we're the survivors
we're the descendants of the people that
survive that [ __ ]
so it makes com it makes perfect sense
but here's the thing dr price in one of
his little videos i can show to you guys
want to contact me personally it's on
it's genesis study on youtube
he actually reads the original story
from the epic of gilgamesh and the
original is much better written
it's it flows like i read an epic of
gilgamesh in my humanities class yeah
epic is my first year of college
it is i agree yeah it's a lot better
written it's a lot more flowery language
it talks about the gods [ __ ] crying
and agony as all the people were dying
and drowning and they were like why have
you done this to them and
not
agreed with the [ __ ] flood see
yeah it was it was what was his name it
was our oman or us
or was it or was it
i don't remember who it was
might be getting people just confused i
don't remember which god it was it was
one of the one of the mesopotamian gods
that did it those damn mesopotamians hey
whole mesopotamia they were making too
much [ __ ] noise
[Laughter]
stop trying to challenge the gods
y'all are just people
you know how the gods do they all like
they're sitting up there wherever they
are in the world hold down that [ __ ]
noise and they just like get sick of all
the yeah
they get kind of drunk and they're like
[ __ ] i'm gonna flood the earth yeah
oh man no don't don't do that don't do
it don't do it no no [ __ ] man no i'm not
making too much god damn noise
[Laughter]
yeah
oh i'm gonna flood the earth but um
camp guy says that movie the master is
pretty good if you like yeah we actually
really like that one that um that was
the one that was kind of loosely based
on
l ron hubbard uh yeah we saw that one
too long ago yeah that was really good
uh oh tila brings up the seventh seal i
had forgotten about that i think we have
that that was demi moore right yeah uh i
think we have that on uh dvd actually
yeah that's another good religious movie
i remember seeing that a lot um what was
that other one
with mimi rogers the rapture
yeah i remember that one being okay
yeah isn't that the one where
my ex-wife was big into this one rapture
movie that scared the [ __ ] out of her
and she was a god check she did it
and she said like that made her almost
kind of want to
believe it again
she was young at that time and that had
something it wasn't like that it wasn't
like the left behind movie no it wasn't
like that it was it was a horror movie
that had something to do with the
rapture so maybe it was that one so it
must have been that one there was one
yeah because that came out [ __ ] man what
year did that come out nobody believed
it no it's not true but then some people
were being raptured or something and it
was like whoa it's for real you think
it's all fake until it happens yeah that
sounds like yeah i'm pretty sure mimi
rogers was okay then yeah yeah yeah i
remember it being pretty good though
yeah well she loved it even though i'm
watching it being like nah yes she loved
it and i remember being like oh okay all
right you know when it happened so that
i would okay we'll say that one's a good
one too
it just has to be written right and it
has to fit the lore
see
biblical lore it must fit that no matter
how ridiculous it is it has to fit that
or it's just not
it's not going to be done
you can't
soften it and i mean it has to be what
it says
and that's part of the [ __ ] appeal of
that movie
oh wait hold on
yeah they are being raptured oh [ __ ] you
know but when you try to sell too much
[ __ ] like you know you got [ __ ]
you got old [ __ ] what's his name
flying a damn airplane and people would
be around see that's what like the whole
left behind series i don't know if you
know but
that was a series of novels first like
tim lahaye was the one guy who's the
other [ __ ] that wrote it i can't
remember what the other dude's name was
but this was like this whole yeah
apocalyptic christian fiction thing and
they they made bank
out of all of these left behind was
obviously like the first one that was
like the most successful but they wrote
a [ __ ] some of them i don't even know
how many of them there were
and not only they made that one with
nicholas cage and i think they made a
couple of other ones but i think they
did like remakes of them later on or
like other adaptations
i remember the nic cage movie i saw it
and i thought it was i remember thinking
it was okay but i haven't seen it in so
long they i'm pretty sure they did that
on on god-awful movies yeah i remember
it's like okay they've covered most of
the like big ticket christian movies and
a bunch of weird-ass ones that that
you've never heard of too now
dudes in the army were reading the left
behind series the books and they said
the books were good
but i hadn't read them but that was a
long time ago at all yeah they were
hugely popular yeah i didn't even like
know anything about christian fiction
but everybody knew about those books in
those days
and they they weren't believers but they
just liked them there was like something
out of like you know the stand
like like you know like stephen king's
yeah like i said if you're not religious
and you don't believe any of that shit's
gonna happen it's just like me like you
know reading a book about a zombie
apocalypse right yeah it's pretty much
the same [ __ ] thing oh yeah [ __ ]
this is like i don't believe that's
gonna happen either so it's just kind of
like okay yeah ooh it's scary
it's like reading trick chick tracks
i used to [ __ ] love those things when
i was in [ __ ] school man we used to
always like i was scared reading them
i was never scared they're like horror
comics i thought they were ridiculous
but um i don't know i guess because i
was always into scary [ __ ] when i was a
kid so i'm just kind of like yeah nice
try but um i i see what you're doing but
every now and then we'd get some weirdo
that like hung out outside our middle
school and gave them out particularly on
halloween and then you'd always get that
one [ __ ] that like put them in
your trick or treat bag
you know what i mean
yeah their house would get egged you
know and tp'd and everything else come
on old man
it's like here you're like one wrong
below that other old man that gives
everybody five pennies
[ __ ]
did you have that person in your
neighborhood no we had the chick tract
person
and we had the
i'm gonna give you five pennies
person scott jumped in the owner's
manual for the human mind that's exactly
that's what it was called exactly right
and like i said so they they didn't bill
it as hey let's lure you into a cult and
take all of your money because obviously
that's not the way to go about it they
were basically like oh it's self-help
it's
self-improvement which everybody was
into back in the day so i kind of feel
like i remember the commercials for
dianetics because back then i didn't
know jack [ __ ] about scientology
so
it never occurred to me i just said oh
it's one of those self-help books
because there was so many yeah that's
what it was marketed to be yeah
self-help book but that's not what it
was it was a trojan horse
yeah that's exactly what it was but um
it was a great commercial that was a
masterful commercial burned into my mind
yeah it had yeah because remember it
asks you like all these questions like
how like how do you blah blah like page
50 or whatever it was because i remember
even comedians at the time like
parodying it and then it's showing the
damn it's backing up and showing you the
[ __ ] volcano [ __ ] blowing and you
don't really know what it is they're
talking about until you know what
scientology is that's the volcano that
xenu was [ __ ] imprisoned in
yeah it yeah does it what was it or is
that it was a volcano that zeno
imprisoned all the [ __ ] things yeah i
thought xeno wasn't imprisoned anywhere
no he was there it was the volcano isn't
he the alien overlord yeah he imprisoned
he imprisoned all the thetans in the
[ __ ] right right and then drop the
time that's what i'm saying as one does
yeah
yeah so you're gonna that's where all
your problems are coming from those damn
volcanoes filled with alien souls that
that are possessing you
what the [ __ ] were you smoking back then
[Laughter]
he did believe that [ __ ] though
people some people have said did elrond
couldn't have believed this he was just
passing this on off on the rubes i i
disagree
he believed it
he believed it because in his final six
years of life
he was [ __ ]
sequestered and hiding only like three
or four people knew where he was
and
he's hiding out from the [ __ ] what
was it was it the fbi it was after him
or the irs i remember who was kind of
trying to find him
and he had people he was ordering people
to make special e-meters
and one of the e-meters that he wanted
made for himself
would deliver a [ __ ] lethal vault of
a lethal amount of electricity to him
that would kill him
and release all the themes
from his soul
and that he would continue on
[ __ ]
without a body
to do research in higher planes
and
yeah
he was telling him to make that and he
was also saying a bunch of [ __ ] and
doing a lot of [ __ ]
and trying to talk to alien souls
uh in his final years so he did believe
what he was saying i mean but the
possibility still exists that he didn't
really believe it at first
but then
yeah then he as he got older and his
brain turns started turning to mush he
started actually believing his own
[ __ ] because i kind of feel like
that happens to some people
you know yeah i'm trying to go back to
the catalog of all the interviews that
i've listened to
from the head followers that were with
him all the time
and everybody liked him he wasn't a bad
guy
he was nowhere near as bad as david
miscavige
yeah that could that dude's like a mega
douche yeah the cult hadn't turned bad
at that time he was popular
um
he would get up there on the [ __ ]
decks of the free winds and [ __ ]
be pointing out all these damn stars and
what the aliens are doing over there and
telling whole stories he was a science
fiction writer
but he called himself the source and i
think he thought he was channeling this
information that's what he would tell
other people
and i think maybe if you [ __ ] get
lost into a world of fantasy
long enough
and you start [ __ ] seeing a whole
empire worth millions and millions of
dollars springing up around you
and you have all these [ __ ] people
that are hanging on your every word and
they're writing all these books
i think you just go i'm what i'm saying
must be true
well yeah i think that's exactly what
happened yeah you're like well i i mean
see that's what happens with anybody
that gets i mean just it not necessarily
even a cult leader but anybody that gets
so famous
that everybody just basically tells them
exactly what they want to hear and
reinforces their uh you know inflated
ego maybe so you kind of like the more
you're around that
you know in that situation
the less uh you know objectivity you're
gonna have about your own self
well
scientology is basically about willing
things into existence so he willed all
that [ __ ] into existence so therefore
he's right that's what he's thinking a
whole empire a whole [ __ ] a religious
empire
so
he would go oh i must be writer none of
this would have happened well yeah it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy like i
am channeling
knowledge of the universe and i am
helping people so he's thinking like
that yeah um it's very very easy for
that to happen like for you to kind of
go from yeah making all this [ __ ] up
just to make money to the longer it goes
on and the more you get away with it
yeah the more you have followers the
more you're successful
then it's going to become like a
self-fulfilling prophecy you're going to
be like oh well maybe i maybe i am
honest no didn't miss cabbage believe it
no i don't think so i don't think about
miss cabbage thought i think miss
cabbage nib is [ __ ] he doesn't know
much about scientology he seems like
just a cynical
douche he's just trying to control a
mass of people and trying to get he's
got his hands on an empire worth a lot
of money that's that's
and he knows that he's selling a product
but i don't think he believes in the
product
most of the people that know him says he
doesn't know anything really about
scientology he doesn't practice
he's just trying to run the empire
yeah he just cares about the money and
telling other people what to do
together because he's on a little power
trip is what he's it's what he's on not
a little power trip it's been i
because he's a little person
it's been going on for a long time he's
been [ __ ] running that [ __ ]
and uh he does have power over those
followers
others just not as many as they used to
be
but i think um
i think guys like miss cabbage don't
care
they just want to to last for as long as
they live and he's getting old
so it doesn't have to last that long i
mean he doesn't care what happens after
yes the thing is like i'm rich so what
the [ __ ] you don't care that's what i
just said why the [ __ ] do they have to
care about anything yeah they're it's
not like their lives are affected in any
way
by any of the plebes down on the ground
no so why the [ __ ] should he get well he
just thinks they're all [ __ ] rubes
anyway that's what i'm saying
so it's like and he doesn't have to care
he gets up in his [ __ ] zillion dollar
mansion every day and has everything
brought to him and
you know he doesn't have to worry about
a single goddamn thing ever i believe
it's basically david miscaviges david
miscavige and tom cruise's cult
that's it's for them yeah that's what i
think it is yeah like i said it's just
they just want all the money and just a
bunch of fawning people to like kiss
their asses all day long i don't think
cruz gets the money i think i don't
think he's getting any money he has
money of his own what he does is that he
gets
prestige and he gets people to do things
for him
through the church
you know they work on his cars and
[ __ ] build [ __ ] for him and he's in
an organization so it's more like
power it's like somebody joining the
army and you can do things and you have
a unit of people you can
command and tell them to [ __ ] work on
this and work on that and then you can
go back and hang out in the [ __ ]
special buildings where [ __ ]
high-ranking scientologists go and hey
go plant me an entire garden of people
yeah
tip guard or two yes sir
yeah so that's what he uh he i don't
it's not i don't think he's in it for
money
miscavige i think kinda is because he if
he were to leave there he wouldn't be
able to do anything for a living he has
no real world skills
so he needs the cult to have [ __ ]
mansions and and yeah because if he ever
had to get an actual job it's like he
would just start talking and his
everybody be like what the [ __ ] are you
even talking about if he had to get an
absolute job today he wouldn't get an
actual job he'd retire
he has enough money to probably retire
on but he likes to be in the middle of
that empire basically be the pope
yeah like i said i think he gets off on
everybody doing what he says and he can
just beat the [ __ ] out of people and no
one will do anything so i think he likes
that too that's like that's part of it
but i don't think that's the main
motivation thing the main motivation
that's just that's that's just like
that's just that he's got private
aircraft and [ __ ] he can fly from one
religious compound to the next
staying in their version of the [ __ ]
ritz-carlton hotel and he's like i said
they don't have to like he doesn't have
to live in the real world at all no i
mean he can just live in a complete
bubble like his entire life and he's got
scientology girlfriends that are [ __ ]
waiting on him and he's just having
he evidently loves stereos you know real
high-tech stereos buying new type of
stereos and listening to music you know
this is the great music ever put on huey
lewis you know [ __ ] [ __ ] like he's
one of those that's nice and american
psycho right he's still like he's still
listening to huey lewis and [ __ ]
it's hip to be square you know yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
i want to hear genesis full phil collins
that's right we all seem to have an
invisible touch yeah you know how that
goes this will touch but
that's what he's doing
john gore says first con rule never
believe your own con
i to an extent that's true but i do kind
of feel like two well okay up to a point
if you do believe your own con i think
as i said up to a point it's easier to
sell because you actually come across as
more genuine
but
after a certain point i think now
uh that it's probably not good
well i think over the years i mean
elrond [ __ ] he wanted to make a
religion he said so
um
pretty much early on but he started off
with the philosophy dianetics
uh but then that mean that meant he had
to pay taxes so he flipped it back
around and tried to make it a religion
again
and he was around a bunch of psychopaths
and
started making a bunch of money and over
the years that [ __ ] did drive him crazy
he did die crazy okay he didn't die
normally
um he died talking to alien souls losing
his mind not eating much and he was
[ __ ] out of his [ __ ] mind in his
final years
if you he did believe his own [ __ ]
if he didn't believe his own [ __ ] he
would have stayed sane
no he believed that [ __ ] and drove
him crazy
that's exactly what happened the stress
and another thing is that he was
not a very remarkable man
who did a lot of cool [ __ ] when it came
to making money and building
institutions and building power
it's almost kind of like a rock star
thing where he got too big for his
britches he wasn't ready for that kind
of [ __ ] i think it was a lot of stress
on him
yeah that far yeah and then he and he
was
he [ __ ] infiltrated the fbi operation
snow white is what it was called the
largest [ __ ] infiltration of a
[ __ ] government agency in [ __ ]
history and it was the fbi mm-hmm
he ordered him to do it he's
his wife went to prison over because he
blamed her
that's some weird because of course he
did yeah he said well i didn't do it she
did it man you pull that [ __ ] on me i'm
gonna like [ __ ] punch you right in
the mouth
he narrowly escaped going to prison and
that [ __ ] was never really the
same after snow after operation snow
white according to everybody that was
around him
so from then on out he was paranoid as
[ __ ] because well wouldn't you be
wouldn't you think that the fbi is
[ __ ]
minutes away from arresting yourself
well well they probably were one and two
i kind of feel like
i think up to then i don't i don't
necessarily want to say that maybe he
thought he was like play acting but i
think at that point [ __ ] got real yeah
and um he never was the same right and
it's almost kind of like he came to this
realization it's like oh [ __ ] i'm like
messing with forces that are possibly
larger than myself and i might actually
be in trouble here dude could it be it
did really should have been life in
prison is really well ideally
cult members joined the fbi as he as
agents and workers there
he had like a lot of them several dozen
of them in the fbi working reporting
back to him what they knew about
scientology he the reason why he did it
is because he thought that the fbi was
on to him and that the fbi knew
everything about scientology and was out
to get him yep i didn't give a [ __ ]
about scientology but the fact that they
did that they're like oh well now we're
now we're interested yeah what the [ __ ]
are you guys doing over there we didn't
care before another thing he did
is that
is that he basically defeated the irs
and most [ __ ] are scared of the
irs death and taxes right not lrh lrh
[ __ ] whenever
he wanted to be
uh recognized as a tax-free religious
institution
he found out who
he found out what irs agents and bigwigs
were on his case and he just had his
people constantly call them on their own
phones yeah he harassed them into he
basically nagged them into saying we are
a religion giving them religions you are
a bigot and they were doing that the
judges and everything and they went okay
fine fine you're religious just shut up
and go away yeah
yeah so
the power of annoying people yeah that's
another thing it's like uh you know i
hear i hear people [ __ ] talking
today about politics and [ __ ] what's
happening on the news and they try to
throw morality into it and i [ __ ]
laugh i says you evidently don't know
anything about scientology
because governments don't have anything
to do with morality and you can bring
any government to its knees if you just
harass the individual people that work
in those offices
they'll go okay that's what the mexican
drug cartels do
all right
the next
mexican drug cartels control mexico not
the mexican government
i mean right on [ __ ] live tv
the mexican government [ __ ] arrested
a cartel dude
so all the other members of that cartel
took out their cell phones and went
outside just started shooting random
people on their [ __ ] cell phones and
posted it to like facebook and social
media saying release him or we'll just
kill more innocent people
men women and children and the mexican
president's okay okay okay we'll release
him and they release that dude
if you think your governments are
actually in control they're only in
control because you're civilized
if you start acting like a [ __ ]
savage no
they'll yield
and there's nothing there's no
difference between mexico and the united
states it's the same individual people i
mean americans think well we got all
this powerful army and all no no no you
can [ __ ] them up too and the courts you
just go for their children
that's exactly what the damn cartels did
you must if you're ruthless enough and
you just don't give a [ __ ] if you're
kind of person that can skin a child
alive on video
yeah you'll be in charge
sad but true
my proof north korea
that's how the north koreans got in
charge
they were that bad
and they're still that bad concentration
camps and everything we're
but let's get back to [ __ ] what you
got
lrh [ __ ] did that same kind of [ __ ]
and nowhere near as bad and he got his
way being bad reaps rewards
the average person isn't raised that way
though
but that's because we're kind of [ __ ]
chops
[Laughter]
if you got enough people in the power
you can do you can get away with
anything
it's sad but true
they're talking about different kinds of
food
yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] hungry yeah me too
actually yeah i mean you know
uh
let's see where was i doo doo doo doo
i'm talking about indian food we're
talking about i kind of want another
drink and i'm also very thirsty is there
more is there more
drink over here oh yeah i got much of it
can you make me one yeah
yeah what's everybody like it's
halloween night what are you guys going
to watch like here it's like 10 40.
so
i might be able to stay awake for a
movie like i said i wanted to start
watching midnight mass but
now i kind of feel like i'm going to get
involved in it
well i know that but it's like you know
we'll we'll get it i'm the one that's
gotta get down there and cook it i know
last night i was gonna start watching
midnight mess last night but then i was
like so sleepy and then i ended up and
then dan bell was live streaming
um
he's been doing like a lot because he
took six months off
um because he was having some uh mental
health issues sadly but he seems to be
doing a lot better now and um so he did
a live stream last night for halloween
he lives in the what's it called the
belvedere right yeah
in baltimore which is like a super uh
haunted it's supposedly like super
haunted you talk about how nice it is
and how cheap it is to live in baltimore
yeah and i've been to baltimore one time
i had a friend that lived there like a
long time ago but um
but it's also the place like if you
watch like the new unsolved mysteries
there was that guy what was his name um
[ __ ] ray rivera is that his name the guy
that um
that supposedly jumped off the roof
or
was pushed off the roof or something and
it was like really mysterious and they
never like figure out like how the [ __ ]
that happened and that's that same
building so he lives in that building
and he's kind of like always
so he does like a lot of ghost hunts and
stuff like that there so like i said i'm
not i don't really like believe in a lot
of stuff but honestly
dan is kind of like
he's sort of like i don't really believe
in it either but then he's like look at
all this [ __ ] weird [ __ ] that
happened like and he films everything
and so
even though i'm not really like a big
paranormal you know believer i still
like all of his uh ghost hunt [ __ ] he
also did one the other like uh
what was it like two or three days ago
he does a lot of um
live streams from lincoln park
uh and all the kinds like shitty like
murders and [ __ ] like that that take
place there and there was this really
really horrible murder that happened
there
like a week ago
like they found this girl
she'd been shot and then like her car
was set on fire
and
um he had been contacted by a friend of
the victim
and so he went down there like trying to
figure out like where it was and stuff
like that but he's like i don't know
like
he has like a really soothing voice and
it's kind of like so every time i see
that he has a new like live stream up i
always like like to watch it because i
like to just kind of like lay there and
listen to him talking
and he was saying like on the live
stream he did last night that we were
watching
um
he said that he got like he sometimes
gets really weird like requests from
people
he said he got a request from this one
person
that
offered him he didn't say how much it
was but he said they offered me like a
significant amount of money
uh weekly he said i'll give you a weekly
salary if you
read me a bedtime story every night like
in your asmr voice like his quiet time
voice because he does these videos
called quiet time most of them are on
patreon but there's a couple of them on
youtube
and so somebody was willing to pay him
weekly for dan bell to like read them a
bedtime story at night which i thought
was like so so funny and he's like and i
thought about doing it but he's like
he's like one i don't think i would have
time and it's like two i'd also be
worried this like dude might be like
jerking off to my voice and it's like
that one kind of weirds me out
it's like
i was like i thought that was so [ __ ]
funny but i was like isn't that funny
that like that's and somebody else he
said somebody else sent him like a
really weird request too but i can't
remember what it was but i remember the
one where somebody wanted to wanted him
to read him a bedtime story and he was
gonna like give him a weekly salary to
like create him a bedtime stream he's
gotta he's got a relaxing stage voice
he does a thing like this and he brings
it down low
and we all need a little bit of quiet
time
that is every time he says that i'm just
kind of like i've watched this he's like
i said most of our patreon i need to get
on his patreon patreon actually because
he's got like a bunch of podcasts on
there him and rick sarah and those two
are like [ __ ] hilarious together
but he's got a few of them like five or
six of them like on youtube his quiet
time ones yeah and it's usually like
footage that he shot
uh because he shoots like footage all
the time like wherever he goes abandoned
places malls [ __ ] like that and for
whatever reason like he didn't use it
for one of his dead mall videos or
abandoned places like because the audio
was [ __ ] up so then he'll like talk
over it and then he'll just like tell
stories he did this really great one
where he was driving where he was
talking about driving across the
everglades and that was really long it
was like two or three hours and he was
just talking about all this crazy [ __ ]
that happened and like all this stuff
that he heard out in the
swamp and everything like that
but i don't know like his voice is just
very very very soothing you know what i
mean
i'm not sure what it is but then it's
funny too because
he'll kind of talk like that for a
minute and then like he'll say something
that kind of like cracks me up and like
breaks the illusion but
you know but that's that's why we love
dan bell you know john's comes in and
says yeah you know cia's involved in
[ __ ] seeding and developing cults and
[ __ ] yeah they have a long history of
that cia bet not good not good it was
never good [ __ ] that's been declassified
that they were doing in the 50s and 60s
was bad
they're still doing that kind of [ __ ]
it's because it's manpower
they can make they get dirt on cults and
they can manipulate and control them and
turn them into [ __ ] operatives
like some [ __ ] out of [ __ ] 007 man
that's like [ __ ]
spectre
yeah i don't trust those dudes the dudes
are bad man
and what's funny is i think it's mostly
just about political power getting rid
of political enemies
and uh money
because uh they can do illegal [ __ ] make
money and it's a black funding that'll
never be taxed
and then those agents can divide it all
up and no one will the government won't
know where it went so imagine you were
able to join
a government sanctioned unit
that was more like a mafia or a gang you
had no oversight you could get away with
all this [ __ ] it's like a license to
steal that's what's going on it's not
some kind of high-minded [ __ ]
where they're trying to get
[ __ ]
american security
[ __ ] line no no no no
license to steal that's what it is
corruption
what's that pookie
scott says there's a documentary on puck
wedgies that's on my agenda
they made a whole documentary about the
puck wedgie
we talked about that on one of our like
uh cryptid shows like a long time ago
is there a band called pukwudgies there
should be
[Laughter]
there should be i don't know it's almost
11 though
yeah we need to like hungry yeah i'm
kind of hungry we probably need to do
like some halloween [ __ ] maybe yeah so
we did have some trick-or-treaters i'm
glad we actually went and got candy we
just honestly it was kind of like four
or five
big groups that came like they came in
truckloads
i got all those hamburger patties
are we gonna make some burgers i can
make some burgers you can put egg on it
you want an egg on it i'll put some
fried egg on it if you want yeah put a
fried egg down there all right we got
any tomatoes yeah got whole tomatoes
[ __ ] we got tomatoes and fried eggs
yeah holy [ __ ] i bought big ones
tomato on the vine man it must be my
goddamn birthday or something yeah
actually not a tomato toasted bun
well yeah okay no mustard
no mustard good
mayo's good ketchup's good mustard is
all right i can do that or leave it you
want cheese
i got monster
oh
all right all right it's my my little
ears breaking all right monster's good
there all right so uh yeah so whatever
you guys are gonna do because i know
some of you guys are in different time
zones so it might be earlier for you
like like i said here it's almost eleven
so
it's i don't know i don't know if we're
gonna end up watching anything tonight
or whatever i've been listening to scary
stories all day so you know that's that
was my halloween thing and like i said
last night we watched carrie
uh and dan bell doing a haunted
apart oh
seriously
had to loosen up a little bit
[Laughter]
oh it's so hot in here i just take my
shirt off
oh my god
you're going to take your pants off too
no i need to pants up
what you might if you if she's trying to
if you're getting a job trying to get
drunk you're trying to give me some of
that root
ew
oh we're going to get to monetize
[Laughter]
everybody's like scary but yes
right up in your face but yeah so uh
thanks for spending halloween with us
you guys yeah this was like a lot of fun
i'm actually like proud that i
made the effort to put on a costume even
though it's not really
oh pokey yeah all right we got to eat
i'm starving yeah
all right so we will see you guys
probably tomorrow uh i don't know if
we'll have a movie to talk about but
we'll come on tomorrow and talk about
something or other
um you know so so there we go um
yeah tammy wait till tila finds out she
missed this yeah dealer already left she
has a red one
oh my god and she missed the happy trail
but
everything's shaved well just you know
happy trailer i know but that's just
that's just what i call the area even
whether there's hair there yeah
okay now you got to stay
all right now i seriously want a burger
with a fried egg okay
so uh so yeah we will see you guys
tomorrow have a happy rest of your
halloween whatever time it is uh where
you are
thank you green spark happy halloween
just caught the very end oh i'm sorry
about that yeah we've been on for a
while we've been on since eight yeah we
came out a little bit past eight yeah
we're gonna try to get something to eat
we're a little bit drunk
once we close it out you can go back to
the beginning and watch it from the
beginning it was a good show yeah we had
we had a good time talking about all
kind of fun [ __ ] yeah uh but yeah so we
will see you guys again tomorrow
probably uh so have a happy halloween
good night